man australia is like straight up nazi
country and a lot of people are like tim
don't use that word you're violating
godwin's law no i don't know it's like
it's like getting there right where the
the the correlation between like what
they're doing with like building camps
and the uh their cyber crime law they
just passed where it allows the
government to go into your device
modify
or delete or add just full control of
your device and i'm seeing a bunch of
people be like uh does that mean the
government could go into your phone at
any time and delete or plant evidence
yeah yeah what are you gonna do about it
that's uh that's australia man seeing
these uh we have more reporting that
like 135 people have been arrested
protesting the lockdowns and i'll tell
you this man
the government's going to use an
emergency after emergency in every every
which way they can to gain more and more
power and you look at many of these
countries you look like well the
commonwealth for instance the uk canada
it's really bad there
it's kind of bad here you know we have
bad places like new york has gone full
fascists but there's something special
about australia in just how like
depraved and screwed up it is where the
rich people around the beach far looking
about like you know they got no problems
nothing to worry about and the poor
people are like yo why can't i leave my
house yeah that's because you live in
you know a country where well i'm going
to say this because the people need to
to stand up and and uh protest they need
to speak up and speak out and say no to
this stuff some of it works apparently
australia's not gonna get rid of their
zero covet policy which made no sense
but we're gonna get into all this stuff
and i gotta tell you this cyber crime
thing is above and beyond insane so
joining us we have a couple of awesome
people one person apparently from
australia apparently are you from sydney
sydney
you know if i was i would actually give
you permission to bully me
then it would be okay but you're not
from city no i'm from the communist
republic of victoria oh okay which is
the extra bad bit right now oh wow well
it'll be interesting to talk to you
about it so i don't know you guys want
to introduce yourself we got elijah too
he's chilling yeah you know it's funny
you were like oh yeah no i'm not from
sydney and you're like i'm actually from
the worst part exactly it's like oh no
i'm not from l.a what the heck i'm from
san francisco it's like oh you're not
not really helping yourself there
but
i have to like i have to lean into it a
little bit because i'm like yeah look
australia's pretty uh pretty jacked
right now but i am from the worst bit
that's the badge of honor that i have
i'm from the worst part well kez because
if the audience doesn't know my wife is
australian i lived in and out of there
for a couple years my family's all still
stuck there they are slaves it went from
like prison colony to free to prison
colony again and apparently at least her
family a lot of them um are still in
like queensland and stuff so they still
have a little bit of freedom queensland
is the last state that hasn't gone
totally off its rockers although they
are building a concentration camp in
queensland still and they're calling it
beautiful and a step in the right
direction and and a way to bring in
foreign nationals nothing says welcome
to
my country like locking you in a
campfire they're building a couple
aren't they like they got one in
brisbane how does that pronounce it
brisbane brisbane
brisbane brisbane also known as brizzy
brizzy's the yeah yeah yeah just light
him like brizzo what what what a
terrible country
you know what it's not it's like
terrible i see hold on hold on hold on
no no you don't get to say you got
spiders that'll kill you kangaroos i saw
a video of this kangaroo and it looked
like the rock yeah like just look at the
third group and it was like
they have these like creepy little hands
right and they and they're sort of like
little t-rexes and they kind of do this
it's it's the creepiest thing they've
got like they have like a huge claw
mm-hmm and they'll like gut you have you
seen them fight have you seen this fight
with their heads back yeah because they
because they're doing their creepy
little like hand thing it's it's it's
super creepy australia is
crazy when we were driving here elijah's
going look at all these spider webs in
the trees is this not this crazy thing
and i'm like maybe i don't notice
because i'm acclimated to the fact that
there's so many spiders and insects and
things that are ginormous that i don't
even notice anymore if this world is
some kind of mmorpg australia is like
the final continent level 50 yeah it's
like top levels like all the monsters
are super big and the spiders are as big
as your face but they're used to it and
here's the crazy thing is they act like
it's normal
this is why you guys are crazy this is
why you guys accepted the lockdowns i
swear because i went to this beautiful
bay okay we don't have this kind of
stuff in america where you can go out
maybe 60 70 80 feet and it's only two to
three feet of water in the ocean it's
white sand beaches and i'm like ready to
go in the water and my wife's just like
hold up for a second
make sure that you just realize that
there are like kind of like shocking
eels here and also just a small note if
you see a beautiful show don't pick it
up because there's these like spike
things and and the chinese people can
check them up and then they stab you and
you die so just like be alert for your
feet when you're walking i said oh a
little tidbit you might die enjoy your
vacation yeah i mean don't go in the
ocean there's iriganji they're these
tiny little they're little jellyfish and
if you get stung by one you're probably
going to uh you know your system will
shut down you won't be able to breathe
you'll die but it's beautiful dude
that's legitimate legit the high level
area why australia why why it's like
that article that said that said when
the guy died from coven and it was like
it could have been worse right it's like
it's like you look at this you go you go
you it's beautiful and it's basically a
beautiful death sentence you go there
and if you don't die from the government
lockdown you walk outside and you're
like fresh air and the fresh air kills
you yeah this reminds me of northrun you
know in world of warcraft where like
around the time when rather lich king
came out for those that are familiar
with the video games and it's just like
this like you know continent of undead
demons and this you know the lich king
and then you have zombies and just like
so you've got the government which is
like
man it's just
we could make a video game in australia
would be an excellent fight did the
british put the monsters there
when they put the prisoners there
possibly guard them and and challenge
them that would be
anyway we should get through the
interview yeah yeah yeah ian ian is
sitting here in crossland what up and
and lydia's i'm also in the corner
laughing at these stories i'm really
glad that sydney survived her childhood
in australia to join me yes
i'm pretty impressed i only had to fight
one kangaroo and it was it was totally
fine did you really fight a kangaroo
did you watch i like i like though
that's mildly believable though it is it
is
i saw a video of a guy punch a kangaroo
because he was trying to get his dog
yeah i'm pretty sure he was actually um
uh arrested after that or he'd been
fined for something for like hurting you
for hurting wildlife or
something you know the road kangaroos
look like you can hit them in the road
people die all the time it's crazy when
you're driving so there's a lot of
warnings at kangaroo crossings but it's
not like here with deer where people
still die here apparently it's very
common that's why the utes their trucks
they all have these grills in front of
them because kangaroos just jump outside
their cars i saw a video of a party and
a kangaroo just like wanders in and
everyone's just like standing there
frozen as the kangaroo bounces around
the party just like and it's massive
because they're like they look like the
rock you know
we'll get to talking about australia i
suppose uh before we get started go to
timcast.com become a member and you'll
get access to exclusive members only
segments of the team cereal podcast of
course we will have a special members
only segment coming up around 11 or so
pm after the show for all of our members
and you'll get an ad free experience on
our fierce and independent journalists
boy are they mad at us i got they wrote
a smear uh one one outlet wrote a smear
about us because we covered a truck
crash with the modern vaccine in it that
the dod was in control i'm like i
thought that was newsworthy and they're
like you're a conspiracy theorist for
telling people that a truck crashed
that's all we said and people got mad
i'm like yo you guys read too much into
stuff
so if you like that kind of stuff go to
timcat.com become a member and don't
forget to like this video subscribe to
this channel share the show with your
friends all the stuff that you know
youtube probably doesn't even matter
anyway but do do it anyway smash the
like button for ian for ian
for kroger jesus christ
honestly did it
let's talk about this the spying bill so
as many of you may be aware there's been
a lot of a lot of news lately about
australia there have been protests over
the lockdowns the lockdowns are the most
draconian thing we've ever seen
meanwhile you know like chris hemsworth
is surfing on the beach and he's having
a smile on his face and even even though
the beach is under a strict lockdown
you're not allowed to leave your house
but the rich people seem to be okay but
everybody else is kind of complaining as
to why they're locked down people are
protesting hundreds of people are
getting arrested and now we have this on
top of it australian powers to spy on
cyber crime suspects given green light i
love how they say cyber crime suspects
coalition bill to create powerful new
warrants allowing authorities to modify
and delete data and even take over
accounts passes the senate that is
amazing they say the identify and
disrupt bill pass the senate on
wednesday despite concerns about the low
bar of who can authorize a warrant and
the government failed to implement all
the safeguards recommended by the
bipartisan joint committee on
intelligence and security and apparently
it was like just like sped through
parliament or whatever is that how it
works you guys have parliament and then
they just like rubber stamped it so
imagine this
you are talking to your friends about
hey you know like i think this lockdown
stuff's pretty bad and then all of a
sudden you get a knock on the door and
they're like we have copied all of your
phone's photos and video and everything
we own it and uh we found ourselves a
crime um cause come on there's like i'm
sure it's similar in australia like it
is here there's just so many laws in the
books you're always breaking crime
you're always breaking laws isn't there
a book about this yeah we we have
someone talking about like
four crimes a day or something yeah four
crimes a day people are committing yeah
and not only that
but if they have access to your phones
your communications and all that stuff
there could be a joke
and they'll be like nope that's serious
you could jokingly say something like oh
you know i would do x y or z
you know and they'll there was like one
story we saw of a guy who was posting
memes or something and a discord server
and then the cops came and arrested him
because it was public so anyway let's
just talk about you know australia is a
country of monsters and dragons and
mythical beasts that always want to kill
you
most of the country is a barren
wasteland of death yes you know also
true and there was a story about a woman
who whose apple maps told her to take a
wrong turn and then she drove like 500
miles into the outback and then like car
broke down and she was stranded because
just like the country is it's it's like
a death pit full of monsters and the sa
the places that were safe the cities
have now been overrun by like full-on
fascism that they're going to arrest you
lock you in your home there's a video of
like a a woman walking on the street and
the cop starts beating her because she
wasn't wearing a mask even though she
had a medical exemption yeah he dragged
her to the ground they dragged her to
the ground yeah that's it so let me
let's just start by asking i'll ask you
cindy what the hell is wrong with you
people
you know i've been asking that about her
for a long time
um honestly it's funny because people
always ask me why did you leave
australia and this is sort of why like
on an ironic note and i don't want to
[ __ ] on australians too much sorry i've
already i've already ruined your thing
i'm sorry all right
i don't want to i don't want to um rag
on australians too much because i do
love aussies but dead set i got to a
point where i was like this is a bloody
prison this is actually a prison and i
wanted it's always been i know but i
didn't realize it until i was like oh
god i'm like the only well i feel like
i'm the only person living in the you
know communist republic of victoria that
actually gives a damn about freedom and
doesn't want to uh live in you know
abject uh government overrun
horribleness for the rest of my days so
i was like let's go to america texas i
know that was like you know you were
begging for freedom you know i was yeah
i want to turn it through that's single
too by the way she's still not married
i'm trying i'm trying so hard i'm just
saying she's not married trying to help
any guy that wants to show her a life of
freedom is trying to help me out she has
the dream of living on a ranch i do with
horses i want some cows oh god cows are
so cute
they'll cuddle you yeah they'll put your
finger in their mouth and they'll suck
on it
apparently it feels good i've never done
it
that someone told me that
i got it i'm a vessel of knowledge what
are you doing in conversation i like
cows too basically that's what i'm
saying
but yeah
no but you know it's funny because you
know i guess they don't know that's my
wife but kez actually said the same
thing if people like how did she just
leave
uh
brought the baby i was like oh you know
how are babies made you stick your
finger in the cow's mouth and then it
all it sucks on your finger
you're on the internet too much
everything i said was true i'm like
lively there's too much over there no
but she was like people go why was she
willing to move over here so quickly
because a lot of people are in two camps
in australia that people don't
understand i would say the majority of
people are very subservient that they
trust the government that they think the
government is on their side if you deny
and you fight against the government to
put into perspective we did a podcast
together and some people that i know
over there were saying that we sounded
communist because we were questioning
the government and we are very far away
from communists go to vash or something
if you want to watch communism don't go
to slightly offensive or sydney watson
our shows but the point is is that
there's this camp of people i would say
it's about one third or less that are
just like we are so sincerely effed and
i'm going to probably need to get out of
here and i don't know how we meet
australians all around america that got
the green card lottery that wanted to
get out because people are so cucked out
and subjugated to this crown and to the
authority they can't think for
themselves and they look at the people
who are against the government as being
like bad behaved citizens yeah like
they're they're bad people morally there
was a there was a manhunt for a guy
because he was coughing in the elevator
well because he had covered because he
because he left locked down because then
well but he apparently he was told so
this is a guy he was told to go
quarantine at a hotel
and so there's video of him leaving his
apartment and they're like look at him
in the in the elevator sneezing
like what
that's a weird thing but apparently they
found him in a hotel quarantining right
and they're like you're under arrest
mate and then they drag him out and
people are cheering
didn't he get like eight months in
prison or something like that no no no
that was that was the protester
well perhaps i'm wrong someone should
double check me on this but i i think
they might have um arrested him and done
like i'm pretty sure they arrested him
like he's a terrorist they put him in
like in garbs and masks and gloves and
carried like dragged physically dragged
him out none of this is new i i can't
stress this enough to americans none of
this is new it's not like this is
something that someone just pulled from
the sky you know the politicians
suddenly were like oh you know what
let's become draconian no this is this
is honestly part of my frustration with
australia always always has been this is
why i left because australians in a lot
of ways and i think i've said this
probably on this show before and i know
i've certainly said it on your show but
aussies in a lot of ways i'm not saying
all aussies but a portion of them view
security as much more important than
freedom so when you have that as the
primary mentality and the primary
prevailing attitude of most of your
population or at least a large portion
of the population then of course what
we're seeing at the moment is a
byproduct of that and people just roll
over because they go oh you know if we
follow the law daddy government will
give me my rights back
honey when was the last time the
government did anything for you i think
it was dave smith who said there's
nothing more permanent than a temporary
government program seriously honestly
like maybe he was maybe he was quoting i
forget who was but he was cool he said
that on this show uh anthony karem has
not been sentenced he was just charged
but he was denied bail and he's been
charged with 13 offenses they called him
public health enemy number one that's
ridiculous allegedly went on the run
i love how in the news report they've
got like five cops and they're like
we're like in swat gear and they've got
a bunch of doctors in full like pandemic
panicked garb and then they're like he
was you know he was refusing quarantine
though he was found in the hotel where
the authorities had told him he should
quarantine and i'm like the crazy thing
about the story is for all i know they
got video of the guy leaving his house
to go to the hotel like he was told and
then they were like oh but why is he why
is he sneezing in public arrest him did
you guys watch the i'm sure some of you
saw enemy number one yeah it's gonna be
merged australians are so hyperbolic
like that like i don't know if you guys
saw there was a news report about him
and the astr there's like you were
talking about the australian commentator
was like this is whatever his name is
adam steps into the it was all so
dramatic and i'm going the dude has the
sniffles what is what do we do what is
happening right now well to be fair
sneezing and coughing without covering
your mouth in an elevator kind of a dick
move yeah not not worthy of a man
hunting was anybody else in the elevator
with him no but still come on yeah
increasingly i was spitting on the
window i don't know sneezing he was
being nasty yeah he's being nasty but i
will say this go to any major
metropolitan area in the united states
and it's quite a similar experience in
fact i think you just fit in but in
australia people are very prim they are
very proper in a lot of the major cities
very clean compared to u.s cities
are very clean they're very orderly yes
and what i want to point out that people
don't know is that australians are also
like super based with their immigration
policies and have actually take
everything very seriously they could be
a threat to their culture to their
ethnic uh their mono culture to any of
these things they see these as huge
threats so it makes sense that you could
also take another enemy that could
threaten you and they have that island
mentality where it's like we can keep
covet away completely because we're on
an island and so they've taken it to an
extremity to where people thought and i
think this is crazy but they thought
that they could essentially remain
isolated from the world and never have a
cove death in their country ever as if
respiratory illness what new zealand did
too yeah would never ever find their way
in you know what's funny i posted i i
posted on twitter something to the
effective you know i didn't really ever
expect to be at a point where we would
have these quarantine camps and yet here
we are and someone responded and i have
to give them props for this they
responded and said sydney you literally
take your asylum seekers and send them
to an offshore processing detention
center and i thought to myself yeah one
that i've actually defended in the past
so i'm in australia yeah yeah so what we
do is because we call them boat people
just you know based yeah that's awesome
and the boat and the boat people come to
the borders and obviously the australian
police or whoever deals with it you know
the board of protection goes
nope and sends them to christmas island
conveniently named christmas island and
not so has nothing to do with business
um and there they stay
maybe indefinitely i'm not sure so
putting putting your own space ship them
back a lot of times they ship them back
but i mean it does take a long time and
these people obviously burn down the
facilities and break things and you know
molest and raise the signs on the
beaches are like if you see their their
immigration signs it's something out of
like what would be considered here
extreme right wing which is basically
just means being epic um where it it
basically just has like a warship like
almost like tipping a boat of people and
it's like don't come here don't come
here you're gonna get tipped like that's
basically what it says
it's weird it's so extreme like you
might die if you try to come here we
have a deal with um papua new guinea and
it's basically like hey we'll send you
all the asylum seekers we just don't
want to deal with them but i guess the
thing is right those are not citizens of
australia yeah here take them take them
these are not citizens though so i mean
it sounds heartless and i don't want to
get into the immigration debate
necessarily but it sounds heartless to
just be like yeah okay but you're you
can't do this crap to your own citizens
these are people that live work you know
contribute to your economy pay taxes the
crown can't abuse their own citizens
have you not seen this have you seen
anything on the crown yeah
it's bad yeah i want to i want to
highlight the the crown's act like
interactivity you love this don't i do
because your favorite people are like
you you [ __ ] the queen has nothing no
power it's all ceremonies i'm here to
back you up royal ascent is a thing yes
the queen doesn't want to approve any
anything that's ever done she can say
i'm not giving royal assent well so with
our legislation and this is not widely
known and i don't think outside of even
australia in australia it's probably not
widely known the queen does sign off on
all of our legislation called royal
ascent um i'm not sure if it applies
anywhere else but it certainly applies
to our legislation the prime minister
right back in her 60s case yeah yeah
back and forth she did yeah she did she
fired she fired the uh so goth whitlam
was the pres not the president god i've
been in this country for too long it was
the prime minister um and she she fired
him and
fired the government so you're not wrong
nope you're actually thinking of
yourself as a better man well even
so her any of the people that represent
the queen in australia can actually act
on behalf of the queen they can fire
governments they can again they can turn
down legislation they have a certain
grace period where they can do all this
stuff um i don't know if they have any
hand in repealing legislation i'm not
sure about that but they certainly do
have they they're they're the queen
makes decisions she could theoretically
make decisions it's not just a symbolic
thing she can actually do it yes but it
is symbolic right now she never does
like anything that happens in that
country is because the queen wants it to
happen that way sure theoretically yeah
you know what's really cool when like we
were all like hey o king suck it yeah
and then he was like oh america and then
the frenchman we will sacrifice our
government to allow you to screw the
mouse true yeah they sacrificed their
monarchy dude i mean they didn't know
that
when you describe it that way yeah i
don't know
this is kind of weird but i was talking
to beck good old glenn beck uh pretty
deeply about this stuff and kind of what
he was telling me though is
unfortunately when we talk a lot about
people are like it's gonna be a
revolution we gotta we gotta fight back
you know i mean i was at the capitol
today and i ran into an officer who i
saw on january 6 and we were talking
about it and i'm not going to get into
much details but you know he got pretty
injured there's a lot going on and um
and he just kind of was like hey i've
actually been wanting to talk to you and
i don't know how we ended up running
into you on the streets here in dc again
and we were talking about and i was just
saying yeah like this is a confusing
time in in our country because we
it's hard to make sense of things uh of
what's going on what our future holds
and that kind of told me i asked him the
same question hey like what does the
future hold for america what does the
future hold for australia what what what
does it hold for people who are saying
i'm sick of this uh present
tense version of chat but like i'm i'm
sick of this you can't say the word but
i'm sick of this and like what do we do
to dust yeah to overturn this how do we
fight back and you know he gave me
something that's kind of disconcerting
but also bluntly honest he said we're
never going to see a type of revolution
like we have seen in the past because
simply put every one of those
revolutions including the civil war uh
the only reason the tides turned is
because a foreign government that had
interest ended up investing money into a
group that ended up winning for instance
in the civil war there was great
interest the french had in seeing the
british empire decline and so that's why
they funded us so heavily because
anybody that could weaken the grip of
the british empire opened up trade for
them and also even he said even in the
civil war which i didn't know
the money was pretty unilateral from
european countries between the north and
the south because they were really
afraid that if the south ended up
winning that they would be end up being
tariffs and problems with trading with
cotton and different and different trade
deals so they kind of sent money to both
sides and it wasn't until i forgot which
battle it was but there was a turn in
the battle that they took their money
out of the south and gave it to the
north which ended up giving them the
upper hand to win and so if you look at
even american history the fight against
tyranny or the union trying to win back
the country or whatever people think
always involve foreign money and now
with this global economy this global
interest right after wilson sold us out
to the federal reserve and you have this
global banking system where companies
you know are against american
traditional values there's no
corporation or country or banking group
that's going to just come in and fund
let's say a revolution in australia to
fight back it would be a guerrilla fight
probably more like the taliban but even
the taliban has some people say it's
funded by pakistan some people say it's
supported by iran
there's a country that's going to fund a
revolution in america
who china
for the left
yeah true yeah they're gonna they'll
they'll invest in in in tons of these
programs they'll they'll place you know
uh spies all over the country and
they'll start putting out woke
propaganda which they're doing which
destabilizes the country it sounds like
what's already happening yeah no no no
i'm talking about i'm talking about what
they're literally doing i'm not
predicting anything china would do the
same thing in australia i mean they
probably are but they probably well
that's exactly it so daniel andrews
actually the premier of uh victoria
because we don't have governors we have
premiers um he at one point well
actually i believe he's taken ccp money
but at one point you should find the
clip if you guys are interested there's
a clip of basically um a victorian
police station i believe playing some
like communist anthem chinese communist
anthem or something
rather than the australian national
anthem or perhaps or maybe maybe i'm
getting my wires crossed and they're
flying the chinese flag i can't remember
but the point is that they have so many
little creepy ties to the ccp that it's
like oh that's where everyone's in
freaking perpetual lockdown beautiful to
go back to what you said there's there's
a different reason i think you're not
going to see a revolution like any of
these past civil wars or revolutions and
it's that we're in a new generation of
warfare why should anyone need kinetic
warfare when you can simply post a
series of tweets and convince someone of
something and then they'll be on your
side is that why they say communism was
never tried correctly someone told me
that that meant that they were always
using initial violence to purge rather
than social pressure for allegiance and
that the way that they're kind of using
this is to bring people into state
control before they have to do an
eventual purge imagine if i said to you
no one's ever tasted unicorn no no
person has has ever really tasted true
unicorn you'd be like unicorns don't
exist hey you're starting to get it
there is no real communism this idea of
this like everyone owns everything
utopia makes literally no sense it's
it's just like saying unicorn so when
they say real comedy has never been
tried you're like yeah no one's ever
ridden a unicorn i get it
you're not going to it's never going to
happen and the only way to do it is to
take some kind of fake horn and jam it
onto the face of a horse and bolt it
down or something and the horse is all
screaming and you're like it's a unicorn
i swear
that's basically what they put alex
jones there sticking sticking fingers in
cows nods boating stuff your horse is
gone
there's a tweet you would laugh at this
because you're i always think of like
your little face you're just like like
that weird face
face yeah but somebody somebody wrote it
was like a meme and somebody wrote they
were like yeah i can't wait till
communism um is you know finally comes
in because i i can't wait to figure out
what i'm gonna do with my farm and then
it just kept zooming in on my and then
it was like
my farm
somebody was like
somebody tweeted what are you gonna do
once communism is finally achieved yes
and then someone responded probably take
some new classes hang out in the town
teach people how to grow vegetables on
my farm spend some time with the family
and then someone responded with your
farm yeah yeah it's like horrifying
these people don't understand just to
see that response from someone about
what they're going to get to do in
communism it's like yeah
back to that just just look at what the
north koreans are allowed to do all
right that's what you'll be allowed to
do starve to death yeah you have at
least three options of haircuts yeah at
least they can get haircuts in north
korea because in a lot of cities in the
united states we weren't allowed to get
those that's crazy because you would
hear that two years ago so lydia i know
this too because you're like pretty like
free-spirited person and so you would go
to a point where you would hear oh
they're like
litigating what kind of haircut you can
get me you can be prosecuted or fined
for going against a haircut that's crazy
to live in a society where they would
the law would get into getting haircuts
and then all of a sudden i remember i
had to literally do a drug deal
basically in in
california by like paying a guy cash
going in through this back door to get
my hair haircut and it was it was like
the windows were covered and i was like
i thought it was like a human
trafficking situation and it was just so
i can get scissors to you know trim my
hair and i'm going we went quickly from
that seeming dystopian to that is they
have more freedom with their hair than
we do
oh yeah honestly just just to this thing
about this just made me laugh because
jack pus i just want to say this because
it actually made me laugh and i think
other people will find it funny too jack
pasobic responded to that thing you're
talking about and he posted this picture
that said oh you thought communism would
support you so you could write bad
poetry and sound cloud rap all day
instead of laboring in the fields haha
please face the walls oh yeah
just like
what i like to say to people what i
usually say is i'm talking about ubi but
it applies here too um
uh how many people do you guys know play
guitar
a couple a handful a handful yes um and
how many of them are really bad at it
uh a handful a handful of them yeah yeah
and and will those people
be like if if they had the option not to
work they'd be like i'm going to be a
musician
yeah i will probably
yeah so yeah
do we need
not none yes
so there's two problems here one we
already have too many people who want to
make careers out of non-productive
fields though i love the arts and think
people should try to make art there is
an issue where in our society over the
past several decades or generations
they've been like instead of inventing
things why don't you try and be a famous
singer because i guess people make a lot
of money doing that so we prioritize
that now we have a lack of trades people
and we need people to you know fix our
toilets and build our houses and there's
much there's very few people to do it
and there's very few truckers but i tell
you this these people who want communism
many of them are these bad guitar
players who are like i hate working at
starbucks if we were communist i'd play
guitar all day it's like dude you'd be
breaking rocks all day yeah exactly you
think they're gonna no they're gonna be
like to each according to his needs or
was it what is it from each according to
their means to each according to their
needs yeah bro you don't have very much
means or needs why would they give you
anything or let you do anything your
means are you got arms and a rock needs
to break we're not going to ask you to
solve any equations here buddy into the
fields you go you know what's funny
though is is speaking of like people
actually being dark yeah it is it's sad
please face the wall um
in it you know it's kind of weird
because as much as we're going to
probably um rage against australia rage
against the machine in australia in this
episode
what's what's kind of funny is
australia's actually got down pack quite
well that whole making people useful
thing because tradesmen or we call them
tradies in australia there's tons of
them because people don't waste their
time trying to be bad musicians it's a
very american-esque thing in my opinion
because there's a lot of entitlement in
this country much as i love living here
and much as i love americans there's so
many great qualities of americans
there's a ton of entitlement that i find
exceedingly irritating that aussies
simply don't have aussies are much more
humble much more willing to take
criticism in some capacity than
americans would be and and there are
these things where again when we talk
about these like communist ideals and
things that's why like elijah was saying
before aussies are actually quite
resistant to it it's more the fact that
they trust the government too much which
is why it plays out the way that it does
whereas americans weirdly enough are you
know i think that there's probably a
bigger proportion of them that are like
oh communism could work because then i
can play my guitar all day and you swore
again tim i'm sorry yeah it nearly came
out of my mouth i said no no but stopped
my stuff caught it i stopped after after
this is what she does she's a women's
sabotage they subvert but also it's true
but
we have to inform tick-tock that is not
true and it's a joke yeah tick-tock
actually took down one of our videos
really yeah for one it's like a joke
like this yeah we won't put it up okay
i'm kidding she'd be happier at home but
this is what this is okay but but
but
but
a reality though is that this is where
people don't understand with australia
and being orderly is people someone
could tell call me racist for saying
this it's just called living in los
angeles and the reality is one of the
things that struck me as the most odd it
wasn't the spiders and it wasn't the
little death creatures that kill you on
vacation in the water
it was i remember seeing how and this is
going to offend some people but
understand where i'm coming from here
that
being a tradie wasn't seen as being blue
collar is in america meaning when you're
going down the 405 or the 605 freeway or
something in california there's a very
distinct look for the majority of people
working for caltrans or on the streets
of most of them are hispanic a lot of
them are overweight unhealthy there's
always a joke right that how many people
does it take to uh
to dig a hole in california on the road
one to hold the shovel a bunch to stand
around looking at this yeah nine to
watch and one to dig because that's just
what it is this inefficient expensive
mess of people who not all people are
but just this this government waste
project i was shocked and they're
usually late 30s mid 30s late 30s when i
went to australia younger than me
when i went to australia it is these
young men 1920 cut chad looking
jaw dudes who are just masculine
dressed pretty well not they're so gross
good good haircuts like what we would
think of being like
a a navy seal or something this is what
it looked like and they're just
efficient they're moving i saw a project
get done like one week on the street
and i remember like going in even into
the state sponsored you know alcohol
whatever whatever those things are those
like big stores where you can only get
alcohol at uh because you can't get in
the supermarket the bottle shop yeah but
the big ones what's that one the bottle
oh the bottle shop
like dan murphy but like but the line
there was like a line of people that
were all dressed like tradies buying
their beer getting ready for the night
like you could tell they had this
regimented lifestyle and i remember
talking to to my wife and she was like
yeah like being tradie is not looked
down upon here like oh you didn't go to
college you became a tradie which is
actually a detriment to our country
because that's the point is that we've
created a system of work where college
is you know matters i think you just
made a tweet about this that about what
that you know that why would you want to
oh
imagine imagine hating your kids so much
you send them to college yeah but that's
my point but they're being traded the
civilization isn't set in this tiers
like that kind of work is still seen as
like you're building the country you are
you are building the the the framework
and a good job there is good for the
nation the nations are very united in
that way and so it makes sense that they
would fight against
like this there's a there's a bunch of
tall ripped chiseled
white men yes who are building the
country and want absolute government
control and spying on all of your stuff
it's weird isn't it this is this is a
nazis it's really really really odd
because on an ironic note look at chris
hemsworth tradesmen a lot of people
don't realize jealous tim you're jealous
you see asian in you you'll never be a
full aryan oh wow okay geez dude took a
weird turn
when you go there when you go there i
even feel like i feel not white because
they're they're like even the girls said
like everyone there's like tall and good
looking and i go down this like ugly
little like pudgy freckly freak and i
like sit there i'm like gosh well i got
the irish jeans like those are not that
good i do say this all the time that i
think australian men are objectively the
best well i think australians are as a
general rule very very so like in
australia chris hemsworth is ugly no
he's just standard he's like he's like
below he's below average they export him
out to the us like they'll like now you
know what she
like i look at some of the boyfriends
that i had in australia and i like
contrary to popular belief i'm not and
elijah can back this up and i think you
can back this up now too lid um
basically like i'm not a shallow woman
like i like brains i want you to be
smarter i'm not like other girls i'm not
like other girls i'm quirky okay but i
like smart people i want to be
challenged i want to you know someone
interesting who can talk
we have a picture of uh one of sydney's
ex-boyfriends right here do we is it
chris hemsworth yeah no it's that mean
guy
you know the black and white photo of
the guy who's like chin is like oh my
goodness i'm just kidding it's not a
real person i do love i do love a good
chin no but on a serious note like i
look i think back to some of these
boyfriends i'm like oh my god they're
actually like very handsome people like
unironically just like normally handsome
people because aussies are attractive i
don't know i don't know other people
back me up here i think horses are hot
it sounds like they're in bread is it
true to a point if they're not allowing
the boat people in
what is happening part of why we're so
beautiful as humans is it true that the
tradesmen are super hot too like tradies
are so hot and they wear these like
little little um they wear their little
short shorts but i love oh my gosh and
they wear their little boots which look
really cute with their little like you
know high-vis stuff and i'm like oh god
the temperature's rising in here
i've been single a long time guys no
it sounds like australia is missing um a
storyteller of people that want to be
storytellers and the america is overrun
with people that want to be storytelling
we don't want your storytellers so you
can keep them right like it's an
important role in society a job even you
could say as an actor you know they're
highly paid musicians just the shaman
that would tell the tribe but we don't
need 100 million storytellers you know
you just need really good ones at the
top and it's such a a small group of
like you know people want it it's like
this this exclusive group that people
all want to do and so they're sitting
around lazily waiting to get their
chance or to get their viral video that
now they get to be this no ian i think
you you fundamentally don't understand
industry in the united states like the
overwhelming majority of movies and
music are small businesses
i
i don't know you said you were an actor
before but i don't understand how you're
not aware of the fact that like most
films are small films no one ever sees
because they'll get like a thousand
viewers like i know tons of people in
chicago who would do uh short films and
they would it would be at a small
theater in chicago to a thousand people
over a weekend and that was the end of
the film maybe and those are jobs people
are getting paid hundreds of dollars to
do and they would have budgets of like
five to ten thousand dollars and they
would film for a day or two right
because if someone wanted to be a
storyteller they would just start
telling stories on the internet they
would make a short film a
low budget film instead people maybe
they want the fame they want to be the
storyteller they want they want everyone
to listen but a lot of those people
story to a dark closet you know what's
the point of the story really a lot of
those people won't make it because
they're chasing the wrong thing what
makes you
famous is your passion for what you're
doing and i'll give you an example i i
i was once doing this voter registration
thing at a death cab for cutie con
concert and they're like you know this
indie band i don't really know what
they're been doing this past decade or
whatever but i saw the band hanging out
backstage and i asked him i was like do
you have any advice for making it music
and uh the guitar said just keep playing
music because one of the things that
happens is everyone around you just
quits they eventually give up they quit
they stop playing and then eventually
you look around and realize you're the
only one left and you've got this big
back catalog of all the music you've
produced and a lot of people are
familiar with it now because you know
everyone else is gone and i was like oh
wow i'm paraphrasing because it was the
gist of the conversation and it's like
if you stay true to what you believe in
and you're playing music and you're
doing what you love eventually you're
getting better at it every day you're
producing a lot of it more and more
people start to see it and the people
who don't really want it are like i just
want to be famous and they start
quitting and then eventually it's like
five ten years later and people are like
oh yeah i've seen that band before
they're really good and they're sharing
your stuff every single day someone's
playing your song someone's hearing it
so that that's true for like most things
you know it's funny though because i
think that that actually applies to the
job that i guess we all do in a sense
because i feel like there's a lot of
people out there who look at this and
think i could do that and really i mean
anybody who could if you're you know if
you're uh well spoken if you're well
read if you will take the time to look
into politics all that sort of fun stuff
and i think what bothers me a little bit
and sorry to derail this but you just i
just think this is a you know decent
caveat to what you're saying um there's
a lot of people who get into it wanting
to be famous which i think i think
that's the worst reason to start doing
political commentary to be completely
frank with you because it's not easy you
really have to be on top of it and all
credit to you actually tim and i'm not
blowing smoke up your butt but you're on
top of this stuff it's like you you like
live and breathe in and just like you're
like a little swamp creature that's
surrounded by all your news articles you
know like yeah i have like a nest of
like exactly newspapers that i gather
and you just she says hemsworth is
standard normal and she called you a
swamp creature wow
your audience is going to be like never
bring this girl back ever again put her
in the bin no but seriously
it does bother me that how people are
like oh i want to be famous i'm going to
be a political commentator and it's like
well
oh take a run like a red hot crack at it
take a run at it fine but i don't i
don't know about that well they do i
know plenty of people who who try like
it's like the stupidest idea you know
that's what i think too it's it's not
easy you get a lot of hate mail i think
everything that's the dumbest idea but
then this is what wanting to be a
political commentator to be famous
because trump made it but around trump
time it became cool yeah because that's
the whole point is that you got i'm not
going to call people out by name here
but it became not just like a grift
thing but it was like for the first time
the politics right is hollywood for ugly
people and so for the for the first time
now you have a movie star i mean we had
reagan but you have this sort of
television personality it's got this big
personality about fame and kind of out
there and it's all about the shows and
and going to the uh convention centers
and go into all the speeches and so this
whole sub tier all these non-profits
develop and all these people because of
social media could put maga in their
name could do anything for trump and it
was seen as like counter culture cool
and because of algorithms you could get
this following and so you could be
anything with maga and you could be cool
and so the problem with that is is that
it became about celebrity and so our
side became very much that you actually
could be cool and could make money and
could get ahead without having any
bright ideas or any ability to make
right and i mean everybody i just mean
like you're you you put yourself in a
position where a lot of people will
despise you not in the algorithm though
because algorithms used to work that you
would think that everyone liked you
because you're like oh yeah you're
you're well that's why
you know for the people who didn't see
what was happening that's why you have
some you have so many of these youtubers
who are like on the right and all of a
sudden they're like actually i'm on the
woof and now they're just like saying
stupid establishment talking points that
don't make sense to try and pretend to
not be conservative because they realize
like hey wait a minute all of the big
money big tech big hollywood yeah
they're banning people who have these
opinions and they're funding people who
have the other opinions and all of a
sudden they found themselves on the
other side of those opinions because
look you want to be famous on the
internet and you're willing to put the
work in i don't know play fortnite or
minecraft or whatever the kids are
playing make more money too yeah it's
it's absurd i i you go to twitch and you
look at like the the 100 000 concurrent
viewers viewers that someone's getting
from you know playing some some video
game and talking about drama stuff
and and sure you still get haters you
will
but you can see there's a lot of
celebrities there's a lot of actors and
actresses and musicians who make all the
money in the world if you're willing to
put the work in and everybody just is
like oh they're pretty cool people like
kendall reeves who hates keanu reeves
like nobody i want to know the names
because i'm coming for you give me the
link right everybody loves the guy
it's like he's like he's a cool dude he
minds his own business and he doesn't
even hover hands
yeah he doesn't want to offend anybody
yeah he hover hands woman he knows so
that he knows the game so much but he
knows what he's in but like but but what
you were saying was a lot of people do
want to do this and that's the problem
they have no substance because it's not
their passion so not bring anything new
to the table that's why they fizz out
because eventually people get tired of
you i think people look at it
objectively and they go that looks easy
i can do that not realizing how much
time effort energy goes into it not just
even on like just for example i said to
my mum recently because she's just dying
of just sadness in melbourne at the
moment just under lockdown and
everything and she's having my whole
family's having a hard time especially
especially my mom and so i said to her
because i wanted to give her something
to do i was like hey i could make videos
a lot quicker if i had someone helping
me do all the research because i'm a
one-man band i do everything myself and
so i said would you mind helping me my
mom is a very very intelligent woman i
thought that might be something that
would occupy her brain while she's you
know dying in bloody lockdown so she
says yes of course and so she starts
helping me a little bit with with
researching and then she says sydney i
actually didn't realize how
difficult this is you know how you have
to find qualitative sources how you have
to read just so much information even
just to get to the kernel of what you
needed to go into this part of the video
and this that and the other and i said
yeah it's not like you just wake up and
go i made a video and then just jot
something down and jump before i'm
hanging out i'm sydney no it's like it's
this whole in-depth thing so what you
find is that and i'm sure that you guys
have seen this too and i'm sure you can
think of use
i can't speak english i'm sure you guys
have seen this too and you can probably
think of people off the top of your head
as well who've done this but they come
onto the scene they go this is easy i
can do it too which is again fine take a
running red hot crack at it the more
people who can support right wing
ideology or you know moderate ideology
whatever fine i'm happy with that and
then they fizzle out because i find it's
not easy it's not easy and that's why
tech talkers make me so cross you know i
turn the sound off and they're just
doing this i've also seen people
say like that's i can do that and then
they do it and they would win and that
was phil defranco he in the very
beginning i was making youtube videos
and he started and he was like didn't
know what he was doing but he watched me
and was like this guy's not good at what
he's doing i can do that better and then
he did and then
he said that he saw people doing it
poorly and he knew he could do better i
think he was talking about me and maybe
other people too
that is the move too is it is that it's
like well most of the stuff is bad i
could at least do better i was trash no
research i was getting stoned i would
make videos not a big deal whenever i
felt like it wasn't hands-on
sometimes
no shirts yeah no cows it was terrifying
you know what the secret secret is
though it was raw you know there's
exactly there's one big secret to
success outside of everything we've ever
talked about they say perseverance right
but there's actually one big secret and
it's a good memory
so
you know i i suggest people do memory
games memory workouts because if you
have quick recall that's how you become
witty that's how you're able to connect
the dots and and find points that other
people haven't considered so if you see
a news story where they're like you know
the cow jumps over the fence and you're
like hey wait three weeks ago they built
that fence to stop cows from jumping
over the fence and the cow was able to
just jump over it anyway yo that was a
waste of money then you have hey guys
they wasted you know 100 bucks on
building this fence because remember
last week if you can't if you have a
terrible memory and a lot of people
don't have you know good recall then and
you've got to have a bunch of memories
at once so you can remember a bunch of
things at the same time and then they
all form like a giant over memory that
you can pick different you can see like
contingencies and
you know angles that
it makes you've got to be able to recall
context a lot of you know a lot of
videos are
people will just edit them you know
they'll they'll be talking and they'll
stop and they'll look at their notes and
they'll start talking again and that's i
think what most people do some people
can't even do that because i've i've
tried you know giving people advice and
they're like man i don't know how to do
this and i i just i just talk i don't
know i don't have any notes like i have
like the news stories and i'll read them
that's better that's
swampy creature with all your little
articles around you yeah i've got all
the i i take i take physical newspapers
and i i rub them all over them
up into a nest and then i roll on the
ground on my side and i scrape the dirt
over my body like a chicken chicken yeah
i can test that yes
you know that before people wonder if
this is like a cult or whatever and i'll
tell you the first time the first time
that i came in here they literally did
take make me pick my favorite news
article they printed it out
they ground they ground no they grounded
it down literally into like a pookie uh
pipe and they made me smoke okay this is
this is uh it's absurd
the only thing that actually happened
when elijah first showed up is that we
set the table we chanted google gobble
one of us over and over again we said
trump jumped upon the time in the mirror
and they branded you and that was that
you were part of the club
now when they all stand in a line you
can actually the branding spells
something that's that's very good clever
yeah yeah nobody actually lives there's
like three people who actually live in
this house yeah you drive up you know
it's funny when when uh people ask
they're like oh what's tim's like i'm
like a compound isn't it is that but
would you call it a compound if it was
this exact same thing but like in the
middle of chicago i would not i would i
would call that um that would that's
object sadness object sadness if you
were in there there's a cow outside i
don't know what that's there's no that's
okay
that'd be cool there's chickens outside
i heard goats being tossed around not
literally tossed around
yeah little goats the pygmy goats they
jump on the backs of things and yeah i
want to get a talib
oh my goodness i was walking total this
is so not politically oriented but i was
on a walk with my new puppy i just got a
puppy he's the cutest thing in the world
and i'm like waddling along on this like
walking track and i look up to the side
and there's a bloody pig someone has a
bloody pig in their backyard
was it like a potbellied pig it was just
this like cute little little piggy i
don't know it was it was just pink was
it doing pig stuff
yeah it's too cold
honestly on a side note with what you
were saying though bringing it back i
don't know what we're talking about is
that is that i don't know why anyone
like me
honestly but what's interesting though
about that with with the culture in
society is that i've also seen that
there's not this huge desire to change
or to to have progress like the
progressive movement happens in the
united states which is why the the
politics is also not that interesting in
in australia people are not as tuned in
and the people that are follow american
politics this is the weirdest thing to
me is is i've watched i mean there's a
significant about five percent but
considering there are less people in all
of the nation of australia than there
are just in the state of california um
to find that five percent of an audience
of a sizable audience is from australia
from what i watch i'm sure you guys have
a decent amount of australian audience
as well and the time zones and
everything it's crazy but it's because
they're interested because there's
something different about our nation
where things can change people really do
have the power to change their country
we really do have the ability to take
control of ourselves and a lot of people
in australia realize that they don't
really have the power to change things
they don't feel that innate also a
dedication to their country like a lot
of people don't we're we're starting to
see this here but before it even
happened here like it was seen as a
little bit bogan to maybe fly an
australian flag unless it was a
government building or something like
people are not
for americans bogan is um
like a
redneck no you're using more australian
words to describe an australian word
yeah so darrow is derelict but you would
say like are you darrow for someone
that's like
white trash yeah white trashy
bogan is like those people who wear
flip-flops with um sweatpants and or as
we call them tracky decks what's that
what's that british word that they
they've been calling that's so specific
no no no they call white
middle-aged men it's a chav
no no no no it's a reference to meat
it's a reference to meat gammon gammon
yeah yeah
yeah ham there you go red face australia
has some honestly like australian
england have some really really fun
slang
teach us i think you're just making it
up at this point no you're gonna say
something bad aren't you no
no no no trust me you should trust me
too i think you're already swearing yeah
because she's blushing what's the motion
topically sensitive
um oh well you gotta you gotta give me
some like more context like angry
like a bad word for politicians
uh well in well see i don't know if many
aussies who are watching this would
agree but i like the word flog like when
you call someone like a dead set flogged
i think that's very melbourne though but
insults are definitely
like dependent upon which area you're in
so flog is a good one you can call
someone adero that's also a good one you
can also just say the c word that's also
quite fun common i hear very common yes
very common oh i was in i was getting um
food the other day well actually the
other day and when i was in the shop and
i started speaking and the gentleman who
was who was helping me basically said oh
are you from and i said i'm from
australia he goes oh you guys use the c
word we actually said it he didn't say
the c word he physically said the actual
word and he goes you say this all the
time and i said yeah i suppose we do and
he goes oh yeah andrew's back and forth
i think as i'm leaving he goes all right
see ya
and all these people in the store go
i'm like yeah catch you mate i have a
good one but that isn't a bad thing to
say he called me he he told me
you know
at currently are you so happy about it
they curse so much i'll tell you this
when i when i when i first met my wife
in australia like i i probably hadn't
cursed regularly in my language for for
a year since i was a young a very young
adult or like teenager and completely
left my language to the point where my
wife would say things that i'd be like
baby you you can't say that that's just
that's that's a horrifying thing to say
and now i swear like i've never been in
the military but you would think i had
like seven years on the high seas
me all the time i swear like a trooper
it comes up you're like oh elijah curses
and like why do you curse and i'm like i
just hang around australians and nobody
think no one uses that phrase oh you
curse that's such an american thing like
oh you curse it's just that's called
australian english can you set our
viewers straight on this one you guys
love fosters
uh
it's i never
brandon my new legend my new producer is
going like this in the background you
know what no timothy no
incorrect i was i was going to back you
up
live fact check incorrect so no the
first time i ever had fosters i was in
london and it's because someone said to
me you guys drink you drink fosters and
i was like no we don't and then you know
i've never it's not we don't make it in
australia we drink vb well i don't but
aussie street
why are you lying to everybody
isn't fosters made in the uk i'm pretty
sure it is
i'm pretty sure it is tim have you ever
had a foster's i'm pretty sure if
austria is australian for beer isn't
jose keith also american probably this
is the white plains new york techies
what i'm saying like i think it's i
think it's mis interpolated that it's
actually from australia and doesn't that
mean it's two commercials doesn't that
mean two x's yeah like everybody knows
three three x's is better okay
i make one as edgy joke everyone gets
turned off and here we are i got i got
here we go swamp man i gotta i got a
question
this is uh this is a off topic but i'm
taking us back off everything's off
topic
are we like we were talking earlier
about ever since ian said putting his
finger in the which by the way i think
you could put two fingers i pictured it
that's why i feel dirty you said triple
x and we got the finger and i just like
so many others with their nipple that
they um so
a baby with a nipple thing that they
suck on um
do you guys think that we're entering a
period where you know you say a foreign
nation needs to aid a country's
revolution and that's been basically
historically what's happened that canada
and australia are going to require some
sort of revolution and that they're
going to need american support
are you saying do you think the united
states will invade canada no not an
invasion at all but like the french
supported arms and money to the
americans for the first before the
revolution for two years well let's be
real fine canada's got a lot of oil i
don't know
they got a lot of oil you know america
loves that oil there's such what you're
going to say
australia's far away canada is like the
same country pretty much it's terrifying
to be liberated at this point i feel bad
for the canadians i wonder i wonder what
a paul would say if you ask canadians if
they'd be willing to join the united
states i don't know i'm not saying it to
imply canadians would i'm like i'd be
interested to see yeah like what i
imagine there would be a small
percentage particularly among
uh uh a lot of the more like border
cities they'd probably be like yeah sure
why not but i'd imagine most people
would be like no and most people
probably like what's happening in their
country no joke like i i know a lot of
canadians like the reason these things
happen in these countries is because the
people either tolerate it or or enjoy it
in the united states we're going through
conflict because the red states and the
blue states are so dramatically
different from each other that texas is
like we're not locking down no no mask
mandates and people are assuming in the
courts and florida's like we're open and
new york is like full-on fascist
lockdown no medical exemptions
canada is just like straight lockdown
australia is just like lock em up
so the people there tolerate or like it
in the united states you have a mixed
bag of conflict well it's because when
they try to do something about it
they're arrested in droves and when they
do and like this is the thing right and
aussies get so cranky when you bring
this up and i dare say the canadians do
too but this is what you have with the
disarmed population and i'm not even
going down the gun road i'm just simply
saying that when you have a population
that is unable to defend itself in any
capacity which you are in australia for
people who don't know uh the list of
prohibited weapons even where i'm from
is so bloody long and there's so many
things you can't have you can't even
have a handcuffs you can't have body
armor there's there's
yeah mace mace's band you can't have
basically glass masks you can't have
non-lethal weapons in any capacity and
the thing is
well i mean the thing is that a lot of
people don't realize that aussies when
they go into these situations for
example if you look up the footage of
people in melbourne just for example um
protesting these anti-lockdown protests
and these police are shooting at them
these rubber bullets in there and
they're
capsicum spraying them and they're
chucking tear gas into the crowds and
what have you these are people who don't
have anything they can't defend
themselves it's not it's not an issue of
a disarmed population i think you have
to go to the root of that because even
the united states for the most part
antifa is not showing up to protests
with you know ar-15s and firing them at
cops or anything though we have seen an
escalation in this we've seen antifa
pointing guns at pedestrians and cars
and stuff
the people of australia and canada are
disarmed but mentally not physically so
yes a right that is not exercised is a
right that is eventually lost
what allowed the people of australia and
canada to enter a position where they
have no way to defend themselves it was
not about it is not about the fact the
government came and took all their guns
it's about the people
letting them do it in the first place
showing up we'll put it this way imagine
the will of the people as a giant you
know 30-foot concrete wall from sea to
shining sea built by donald trump and
over the years as more and more damage
is done to it eventually it's eroding
and it's crumpled and then it just
collapses
and they say if only we had a wall you
know we used to have one if only we had
one now that would stop everything it's
like no no there's no will
there was a will to repair that wall the
people who are standing up and saying i
i you know i resist this that's the
level of willpower and over time in
australian canada the willpower
decreased and decreased and decreased
and people became comfortable and they
became fat and lazy and now there's no
willpower at all to resist
the the reason why the second amendment
is so important in this country is not
because armed americans are going to go
march to the streets and and and seize
city hall or anything like that that's i
don't see happening especially in this
day and age it's that the police can't
serve warrants
unless they do it properly the police
can't just kick your door in unless they
get the proper warrant because you'll
look at i i this is a very important one
brianna taylor in the brenna taylor case
briana taylor's boyfriend fired at the
cops who busted the door down and that
dude was cleared of any wrongdoing and
so the cops in the u.s know we got to be
real careful in australia and canada you
see these videos out of canada where
they kick the door and they're like
there's six people in here and the old
guy's screaming and they're dragging him
out they wouldn't do that here yeah but
that's the thing new york they would i
suppose this is what i'm getting at
though and just to qualify my position i
agree with you like i think a lot of
aussies canadians too are definitely
beaten down mentally and they definitely
have completely and utterly they've
resigned themselves mentally for sure i
totally agree with that sentiment
something i really dislike about my
homeland is that sentiment precisely
however police would bloody think twice
before ripping you down onto the ground
and trying to handcuff you or shove
things into your face or whatever
whatever they're doing in these videos
that are coming out of australia they
would think twice if they thought that
there was a potential that you were
armed in any capacity and that you might
actually fight back because you can't
have you can't have a system where the
the population is basically subservient
to the police force you can't have that
it shouldn't be that way that's that's
not how this works and australia doesn't
have the same
the same issues with crime say that the
united states has because obviously your
demographics are very different the way
that your your country is um i guess
made up is very different but australia
so australia doesn't have any of these
issues and the mentality of aussies is
very different there's things about
australia that's wonderful mentality
wise there's things that definitely suck
um but one of the biggest things is that
aussies do believe that the police force
is basically there to protect them they
don't in any capacity i would say see
them as an enemy whereas here people are
very skeptical of the police so when
they do pull them down onto the ground
they're not actually expecting that to
happen in the first place so the the
mentality towards having a gun actually
isn't even there so yeah what you're
what you're saying is totally correct
tim
but not imagine that's part of the
problem
so so you know hearing this i wonder can
like australians actually survive in
their own countries outside of cities
yes because because people outside the
cities aren't there's you know how
there's a big difference between city
people and country people the world over
there yes so my dad for example from the
country he's this like bumpkin human
who's the best person in the world but
definitely like oh she'll be right you
know i've i've grown up with my guns
let's go kill some foxes let's go kill
some rabbits type he's one of those kind
of people um and he he is just no i'm
not doing it no i'm not gonna not gonna
put the mask on that i'm good thanks
leave me alone and that's how people
outside of the cities are it's people in
melbourne city it's people in sydney
it's people in brisbane and blah blah
blah that are like oh yes study
government
government
but is it is it is it only this bad in
like these key areas or is it widespread
because like all of it's new south wales
is like in total lockdown isn't it yes
but yes i mean
yes so
i had a map and it showed like the
outline of the the their states
and it was all red like you could
highlight each and every jurisdiction
that was like can't leave your house
can't leave your house yeah they're
they're all subjected to the same thing
yeah but this is this is where they're
different there and they're getting away
with it though this is why they're
getting away with it this is the key
thing so in the united states you're
going to find a big difference between
police forces in the inner city versus
in the country a huge difference we
already even have sheriff versus police
etc so there's something very important
that police have in general even in
australia which is this this rule of
necessary discretion they can call it
different things around the countries
but this is the same rule where you
don't necessarily have to prosecute or
charge everybody uh or write the same
ticket for everybody that commits the
same crime a good example of speeding if
you have a good explanation just like
here in australia they could not give
you a ticket because it's necessary
discretion you might have been going to
your wife's
recorded and sent back to a major
database so in australia they're
probably gonna but if your wife yes you
probably will but i'm saying still you
could have been like oh shoot yeah like
there was an emergency their blade was
bleeding we're not gonna give you a
ticket we're to go we're going to put my
finger off yeah well yeah exactly so no
but i'm saying
but meaning you you can say okay a law
was broken but i uh this makes sense so
we're going to overlook this what's
interesting is is that here if you go
out you know outside of the cities
you're also going to find a lot more i
mean traditional where like people might
even know the sh the town sheriff or you
know they might even understand this is
just the town drunk and this is that or
whatever it is this has changed as we've
advanced the problem in australia is
that they still keep necessary
discretion with every type of law but
they've removed that from all coveted
restrictions across all jurisdictions
even in the boonies and in the main city
so it's that's created as a unilateral
enforcement where you do not and cannot
use your own discretion when enforcing
things it's important because i i know
plenty of good people that that uh and
that serve in the police force out there
there's lots
there are before you start saying that
all australian police are horrible
michael mal says there's no good police
but whatever he's right about the
australian cops that's for sure well but
not all of them are enforcing this the
problem is
different the problem is is that because
of this necessary discretion what
they've done to the police is that if
you do not let's say give someone a
ticket for a mass for not wearing a mask
you then could get in trouble yourself
so they've created this totalitarian
gestapo in there no no no they haven't
well they have meaning they've changed
what policing means in the country
to be fair they're always going to give
you like they yeah yeah like come on
like the responsibility is always with
the individual like i i just i'm not i'm
not a fan of this argument where it's
like oh those poor cops who are
enforcing the gestapo's laws i'm not i'm
not defending them i'm saying that
people who may have been a cop before
who are thinking i could be a good guy
have been pushed into a corner to where
when it comes to kovid's stuff the
police the policing what it means you
could have been the service for 20 years
yes they're complete dicks they they
they have speed traps that are horrible
they they go into residential neighbors
try to get you going one mile over the
speed limit in unmarked cars that don't
look like they randomly breathalyzed
they're horrifying
but i'm saying that as you went out into
as you go out sometimes the people were
a little more chill a little more
relaxed they're a lot nicer they've
found a way to get a hold of the nicer
police the more relaxed police to
creating a more nationalized police
enforcement
i don't care what any politician says
it's the cop the individual who is the
bad guy so this is the villain they
should absolutely quit resign
immediately slander badge on the table
imagine like to what degree and when we
keep saying it's just it's just it's
just this it's just that it's just it's
just 15 days it's just a month it's just
a mask it's just two masks it's just one
shot it's just two it's just three it's
just f every five months how how you
keep doing that and these cops just like
sure sure sure sure sure because they
have no principles and they're bad
people they were never good people
because a good person and the good cops
they email me they're like i quit as
soon as they did this i said i can't i
can't do that that's a violation of the
constitution and they said you do it or
it's your badge and say here's my badge
people who remain like in australia who
are like i was once a good cop but then
the government told me to do it so i
said okay but a lot of them aren't doing
it because they're finding ways out of
doing kovacs enforcement then good for
them they're getting their good cops
or at least to a certain degree they're
better i'll tell you where i disagree
with michael malus he says there's no
good cop michael says that there is no
i i want to
i'll paraphrase it quote all cops are
bad people he said there is no you know
action so depraved that a police officer
would not do it if ordered up into uh up
and in uh to executing children
something that effect i do not agree
with michael malus
i like him and and i may be getting the
quote wrong so but he he has said like
every cop is a criminal no i think there
are a lot of cops that i've actually
talked to and interacted with who are
like i resigned last week because of
they they wanted to do this thing they
wanted me to do this i said i will not
do it the seattle police chief right
isn't that the same thing where she was
just like i'm not this is ridiculous i
can't do my job resigning but i wouldn't
say that the seattle police chief is a
good person in my opinion based on a lot
of what happened carmen best but right
but but but i do believe that
if you ordered a cop to do something
in the united states a lot of cops would
be like yo i can't do that and they'd
freak out a lot of cops would probably
do it in australia i am more inclined to
agree with the general premise of
michael malus's quote because
they're they're they're locking down
literally everything and and only based
on the way you're describing it they're
willing to just enforce whatever
incitement like these weird these were
watching them
that woman she was wearing a mask and
she's like i have a mask exam she's like
i don't care timothy they pepper sprayed
a child in the face the other day yeah
it's welcome to your gestapo i mean i
feel bad right because truthfully i do
feel bad because i know a handful of
cops back home that are good people that
are friends of mine that are hating all
of this and are trying not to
participate as much as they can
and it makes me sad because um i never
was one of those people that hated the
cops i was always one of those people
that would defend them because i think
there is a mild um i guess people in
australia do somewhat i obviously don't
want to generalize here but you know
from what friends and things have said
they haven't liked the police
historically and now their hatred for
the police is bubbling over because of
what they've been doing to people you
know australia needs what some kind of
like organized exorcism of activists who
oppose the the like overt
fascistic tendencies maybe like a group
that opposes fascism like an
anti-fascist group like we'll call it
antifa
yeah does australia have any kind of
like antifa that could oppose the
authoritarian lockdowns i'm just i'm
thinking that maybe if they got together
and congregated maybe we need a donald
trump in australia to like kick that off
you know
just just to trigger something yeah you
just need to trigger some people in
black outfits running around smashing
they haven't say that they have antifa
for sure in australia i've seen it did
you see the uh the anti-focus oh there's
antifa there i know they've come they've
come to events of mine and like
extinction rebellion has been into that
have you guys seen the video of the
antifa people attacking the group that
opposed uh state mandates mass mandates
yes antifa shows up and they start
they're they're anti-fascists but
they're pro-state they're statists and
that's why i keep telling people like do
not call antifa anarchists they are not
anarchists
absolutely they're communists they're
authoritarians and they're actual
fascists some of them yeah david graber
the late david graber said that there's
an element of the left that has adopted
the fascistic ethos of uh
well the fascistic tendencies not that
to say that they are fascists in the
academic sense or they are nazis but
they certainly believe a lot of the
exact same things around uh and that was
the extent of a twitter thread but they
do believe these things to the extent of
identitarianism government power and
control to the point where they'll be
like we oppose fascism and we'll beat
back regular americans who are upset
with government and corporate power like
in dc when a bunch of conservatives got
together and said we oppose corporate
power and centralization so anti-vicious
are beating people it's like dude if
you're if you're beating people in
defense of corporations and the state
you're a fascist yeah but hey you're
also probably ugly a physiogrammy check
have you seen a lot of them they're
deformed looking and it's so sad because
it really is true they're right this is
who the joker targets haven't you ever
seen the dark knight yeah they they go
this ideology targets people who are
desperate and unwell and so yes
you look at a lot of these interviews
not every single one of them but a lot
of them and they're they're dejected
anti-social and and unwell in a lot of
ways and so they're attracted to a
violent dogmatic mob they're not
fighting for anything other than they
feel pain and they want to cause pain
they look sick you know jason charter is
mm-hmm jason charter's the the antifa
organizer in dc that did he get arrested
yeah he was getting charged for for two
a decade's worth of of uh
of jail time simply because he tried to
pull down the andrew jackson jackson
statue and organize the siege on the
white house but that's what they're
alleging the insurrection yeah well
exactly that forced the president into
the bunker yeah the insurrection on the
actual white house um i i've spoken to
him i've had him on my show before too
and it's interesting because when you
speak to him you know he's disabled he
i'm not being rude he's just got a gaunt
looking he'll people thought think he
looks a little bit like maybe he's on
chemo or something like that he's
pansexual he said this on my show and
it's really i kind of actually felt bad
for a second because what i realized is
that
at a certain era or time in a different
world this guy
probably could have just been like this
guy that would have been rejected from
society but now someone gave him a
chance to fight back and tear down the
regime to tear down the statue to be
known for something and he fell into
this trap i believe he fell into this
trap i don't believe he's strong willed
or strong-minded he fell into this trap
and now he believes he's like a martyr
when really he's just like a terrorist
and that's that's kind of the funny
thing he's actually just terrorists in
the past someone would have helped him
that's what i'm saying
but i'm saying like they could like help
him with some programs and get and get
find meaning in life and some counseling
and get his brain on intact but there's
this instead of helping the weak like
you're saying it's a society that preys
on the weak and what used to either help
or destroy is now about taking advantage
of weak people to carry out their deeds
yeah and that's what we're seeing now
too even with the covid stuff is it's
all about praying on the minds of the
weak and i want to say this is so
important but kez brought this about
australia because of of the rhetoric
coming out of dan andrews and anne of uh
brazilian i don't know what that is
the premiere of new south wales glasses
we see this here on a lesser extent but
what the the premiers are saying is
they they make you be obedient and then
they change the goal posts and reimpose
the restrictions and then tell you you
have to do a little bit more obedience
to get the restrictions removed and then
they remove the restrictions and then
they add them again and then at a
certain point they started saying
this is how the rhetoric went
the you who are obedient this sounds
like a regime you are obedient the
reason why you
are unable to finally break out of this
constant cycle of lockdown and
totalitarianism is because the
unvaccinated the disobedient are keeping
you locked down
and you capitulated you gave it many of
you compromised you got the vaccine when
you didn't want to get it you you put on
a mask and you didn't want to put it on
you agreed with lockdowns when you
didn't think they were right you held
your kids from school and you know what
you know what's happening because of
this small group of people who are still
resistant you have to be punished again
and their resistance isn't just
affecting them it's affecting you and
it's splitting the population against
the subservient and those who are
independent and they're creating this
weak group of people who are more and
more capitulating and more and more are
giving in to hate the people thinking
that it's the unvaccinated that are
causing the problems but it's the
government who are causing them so it's
getting that it's deflecting off the
government it's like no the government
is causing the issues they're the ones
locking you down they're the ones
ruining your life they're the ones in
stating the the restrictions it's not
the unvaccinated people that are ruining
your life it's kind of weird because
like i agree with you to an extent but
just looking at the things that again i
have like all my friends and family
a ton of them are in australia and the
things that they say is stuff like it's
not that hard to wear a mess just wear a
mask and it's like
these are people who are conservative or
at least like who you know lean to the
right or who you know are libertarians
somewhere on the right wing somewhere
and these are people who are like well
just wear the mask like it's not it's
not that big of a deal because i think
the problem is that
and again i don't want to i don't want
to say mean things about aussies but i
think that to some extent people have a
hard time connecting the dots between
government overreach and how that could
inevitably lead to very very unpleasant
things further down the line which is
concentration camps precisely
i mean i know it's it's it's like it's
this it's it's not even an ironic thing
anymore it's it's like the worst thing
in the world that they're building these
quarantine facilities that people
somehow think are normal and again
they're they're literally building one
of them up the road or very very close
to where my family lives in victoria and
it's disturbing in a lot of ways to
think about again how and i was trying
to find the street for lydia just in
case she wanted to you know pop it up on
screen or something where someone had
basically taken these photos of one of
these quarantine facilities and said
well look how nice it is look there's a
pool and there are the people drinking
the coffee and oh this person's sitting
on a deck oh that's freaking great i you
can't leave though
that's oh it's a nice bloody cage i'll
give you that but it's still a cage and
you're not there because you want to be
you're not there because you're in free
will you're not there because this of
your own volition you're there because
the government put you there and you're
defending this and this is the problem
with australians again
aussies are great people nicest people
wonderful people kind people but they
are butt heads sometimes when it comes
to this stuff and this is why i wanted
to get out of the country where's
where's antifa
they're i don't know sitting in their
home in their you know home screen has
there has there been a prominent antifa
presence in australia before not really
they tried but again aussies are very
politically ambivalent so to actually
get a group of people together who are
willing to go and smash things up is
actually quite
we could fly them over maybe maybe they
could um no i mean like in new york
where they've basically said all
disabled people ineligible for the
vaccine will be terminated from their
jobs on the 13th of september
i i don't know why you asking me ask
elijah's yeah yeah
the antifa unfortunately they're the
ones thinking that and siding with the
state they're basically some of the most
easily manipulated piece of
crap people that uh unfortunately
i want to get this yes unfortunately for
us what they are doing is they are
pushing the authoritarian mandates they
are an extension of far-left political
ideology and whatever the far left is
pushing this country they just side with
they don't have any original thought
they are well organized but as of right
now they are being used to bully people
and especially what they are most being
known for right now especially is
attacking anti-lockdown protests even
church groups i'm sure you guys covered
that in portland they're attacking
prayer meetings break uh they destroyed
an entire ministry's office they're
attacking christians now because
christians are being seen as some of the
few purveyors who are against this
tyranny who would it be said that people
who believe in individual liberty and
liberty to christ would not want the
government you know coming down on you
the same government that also like
burned and hung a lot of them upside
down and you know also like killed jesus
but anyway we
we actually need right now based on
based on what we're seeing in new york
we need actual people who oppose fascism
to stand up reject this to protest and
say no
but
i'm i'm looking at uh nyc antivirus they
just they don't care at all they're
cheering for the government on january
6th saw that they love all this sort of
stuff they're like get them boys
something because they're not they're
not anti-fascists they just use that as
a way to recruit stupid college students
who don't know about her well angry
people too something that i wanted to
say actually at the beginning of this
show um and we sort of got very off
topic talking about cows and things was
when you were talking about this this
legislation where you know the
government comes in and can put things
on your phone and all that i think
people need to realize that in australia
especially and i know this is the same
thing here in the united states and i
dare say in most western countries
around the world but australia has some
of the most psychotic legislation
pertaining to what the government can do
to you obviously um but especially
towards like terrorism legislation so
when they pass these extreme things
these extreme measures that are you know
in response to a terror attack or you
know covet or whatever the case is
obviously we all know that they never
appeal them but i think people need to
look into some some of the terrorist
legislation that exists in australia the
anti-terror legislation where like for
example when i was doing my master
degree i did this ethics course and
basically we had to learn because it was
my masters in journalism we had to learn
about like ethics and you know where the
social contract on this fun stuff
and they were talking to us about how if
you accidentally stumble upon
information
relating to some of this anti-terrorism
legislation where you start covering a
story
that that relates to somebody who's been
detained under this specific legislation
you yourself can basically be arrested
for uncovering it and speaking about it
so there's all this psycho legislation
in australia that's actually a lot worse
than what you're even talking about and
it set the precedent for worse and worse
and worse legislation that continues to
infringe the rights of aussies and
aussies don't know and don't care
because they're politically ambivalent
so once again we roll back around to the
fact that am i surprised that
australians are sitting in their homes
and have been sitting in their homes for
200 days plus no i'm not because this is
this is what you get with an ambivalent
population yeah they want it they get
what they want i guess you know we get
what we pay for
no refunds you know i live in west
virginia and it's it's kind of all right
for the most part you can you got a big
empty bit of land play that song west
virginia you'll
no we will but i'm just saying that like
it's funny when you come down here from
texas yeah we drove all the way from
texas we jumped
no you don't but
it's funny the people who are
anti-government like when you look at
who actually killed for instance
throughout all of history who caused
most of the problems right even if you
go like waco and you look at the atf and
you look at what they did was it the fbi
i'm it was texas atf but but but i'm
saying but you go down it's like okay
the government and you look down what's
like
a lot of the things here that are
screwed up but like i was mentioning
earlier with with jesus as well like the
roman government technically killed
jesus everybody says it was the jews the
jews want they were there was that the
pharisees and stuff were wanting his
head but technically the only people who
could order and actually carry out the
execution during that time would have
been the governing empire which would
have been this and you go back through
all of history and like every religion
everywhere around the world look at all
the history at the core of the problem
is a government that tries to trick the
people into thinking that it's looking
out for their own interests but as it
goes rogue eventually it declines
because it loses contact with the people
and you end up having somebody else
stronger comes in and takes over where
they see a weakness to meet the will of
the people and it's kind of interesting
in all of this that
government people like this is why i
never understood why why why black
americans are so democrat it's like
so you're saying the government screwed
you over and allowed slavery and like
brought you over here and then ruined
you and then you know put jim crow laws
and everything so you want to be a part
of the party of big government that that
continues to do this like so you're mad
at the government but now you want the
government to solve your problems they
ruined your life they literally
destroyed they brought you over here and
just continually destroyed your life and
held you back and now you're looking to
that same entity that destroyed your
life to bring you out of it you think
something's changed do you think that
the government is now suddenly good and
they're going to help you like i don't
understand unchecked people will
suddenly be checked and start doing
things that make sense elijah no but i'm
just saying with this government thing
is that it's like it's like nobody has
gotten anything more wrong about about
kovitz since the beginning since
government entities and organizations
everything has pretty much been wrong or
aka suddenly corrected or
disappeared yeah exactly the facts they
said new facts right that's the whole
phrase and so it's like look man i'm
about at the point now where this isn't
working anymore okay you killed my
savior good thing he rose again from the
dead and now i have new life and
apparently now he's on my podcast with
me hey
second coming everyone is it no
the way that ian was just looking at you
as you were talking about jesus he was
like i know he i do love jesus he's
telling my story if we live like jesus
like a real christian embody the spirit
of what you believe is right amen tim
are you yeah
no i'm sorry but uh the problem is not i
just needed to know because i needed to
know if i'm not the only atheist in the
room no i'm not an atheist no i never
said you were a pet i'm just saying so
you're you're the only atheist in the
room i am the only atheist
hold on let me qualify let me qualify
let me qualify now that now that tim and
i are friends we're friends um
i i
elijah can again call like can again
qualify this i say pet all the time and
it freaks americans out because they're
like why are you calling me a pet and
i'm like i'm not it's just part of my
speech what am i a cow
peter are you an atheist you're not no
i'm more agnostic than anything i mean
that cosmic microwave background
radiation is like the permeating
radiation left over from the big bang
looks like it's interacting with matter
and causing god that's the experience of
that interaction as god seems like it
but i believe that this christ
consciousness is real that it can
permeate this like
i don't know what it is like a spirit of
goodness i know good and evil are
subjective but because the holy spirit
the spirit of god is over the earth and
a lot of people mock me from my belief
in god but it's not just a consciousness
like christ is a real person but he's
also god and what's interesting is that
and this is where i know people who are
not christian would not believe this but
the only thing that is holding evil back
is the spirit of god that is currently
on the earth in those that are chosen
and there's going to be a rapture and
that one time that's why the end of the
world comes he pulls the spirit off the
face of the earth it's true and actually
evil continues we have the antichrist
things happen so this is why it's weird
how the bible predicted a one-world
government wait towards the end like
what i'm saying it says what the world
would be like in the end times and it
describes what it would be like and it
looks like the world today well it also
says that there would be the sharing of
knowledge this increase rapid sharing of
of knowledge around the world and a
one-world economy that it would create a
one-world economy a global economy and a
one-world government would be their goal
where you had to have some sort of a
small business yeah where you had to
have some sort of
buyer to sell right and that was like
it's very interesting the mark of the
business about the end says that you
cannot buy sell or trade unless you bear
the mark and when i first heard that i
was a super chat on this show i was like
that that's too specific
talking about free market
restrictions what do you mean and then i
looked it up yeah it literally says you
can't buy something it's possible but i
i have to ask a question on that um
you're saying that the only thing
holding evil back is is the spirit is is
the holy spirit the holy spirit who's
well so does that imply that like god
put the evil here on purpose no it's not
that god put the evil here on purpose
but what vibrated the evil and the evil
no no no so what so what what's
interesting is is that if you look at
actually christian theology or what
actually happened is lucifer the devil
that we call the devil or satan is
actually an angel right all demons are
fallen angels and part of why god is not
a slave master but he's a just and a
fair god is he gives you
free will or the right to serve him or
to not and he is perfect and so what
happened was that lucifer became i could
say jealous but he thought that he was
he was the best of all the angels right
he's most beautiful most talented he was
ahead of all of the music and that he
actually rebelled against god and he
thought that he could be god like god
and so it's kind of interesting even how
sin was brought into the world but he
was cast out of heaven many believe that
means that he was sent down to earth and
that's why there's that big crater down
in uh down in the gulf but anyway a lot
of people believe that but i don't know
how that's how that's yeah i don't know
if that's true but i will say that he
was cast down and what's interesting is
that it talks about that some of these
demons actually were so evil and after
they revolted and separated themselves
from god that some of them are even like
locked in chains at the bottom of like
the euphrates river and they're held
back and that when the holy spirit
leaves that the evil is finally
unleashed on the earth that full evil is
unleashed the reason why the good keeps
winning and the reason why like evil
never fully is able to triumph and
indefinitely take over is because the
holy spirit of god is continually on the
face of the earth and is holding evil
back but there's a moment where god
gives us what we want and what people
want like how aussies want they want the
government eventually you really talk to
them but most aussies like they think
what the government's doing is good i
mean that's really what they need at
least they think it's okay yeah is that
not like what humans want is to not have
to deal with god and then god gives us
that he goes okay
have yourself and that's why the
antichrist is able to rise up and that's
it's so weird to me though that a bunch
of you know i'm saying this
sarcastically for people who can't
understand that
but a bunch of crazy fishermen liars you
know thousands of years ago somehow
predicted that what the end times would
look like is that people would be liars
they would claim to have the fear of god
but not express its power that they
would hate their families families would
be divided against themselves that they
would be backstabbers that talked about
they'd be greedy lovers of themselves uh
haters of god mockers of god and that
the key factors would that there would
be pestilence earthquakes and these
would be signs of the times and the goal
would be the spirit of the antichrist
would be to create a one-world economy
and a one-world government and that if
you that being an allegiance to that
government was part of the the uh
you had in order to like buy sell trade
to live you had to give your allegiance
to that leader who would take over and
declare himself god and it even it even
predicted the rebuilding of of and it
says that we'll know who he is because
he's going to say he's going to rebuild
the temple on the temple mount
where he's going to rebuild the temple
after it's destroyed and he's going to
sit on the throne and declare himself
god and he says that israel was going to
reform as a nation and that it's like
funny they predicted that israel was
going to reform and it did and then they
already have the plans in place right
now and the materials to rebuild the new
temple and they're waiting for the right
moment so it's like it's crazy that like
if it's not real how they got so much of
it right or they read it and said hey
let's do that
that's possible too but i mean yeah yeah
that that could that could be but you
know i wonder if that's such a yep
that's just a really good explanation no
i'm saying that could that could be but
they also don't believe in the new
testament the jews don't even believe in
in that as well so they don't they don't
follow that no i i don't think it's any
one particular group i'm saying like if
you're saying that zionists don't
believe in the new testament if there is
a group of like you know global special
interests who are doing the things as
predicted it could just be those global
special interests are like hey i read
this book you read it hey there's a
bunch of good ideas for how we should
control the world i don't think they're
they really respect why well then why
would they just randomly follow
revelation follow anything i'm saying
they're deliberately doing it i mean it
doesn't give you the plans on how to
carry it out
these are the signs they're too vague to
actually give you a way to carry it out
and then why would you choose that book
i mean it just
if you look at it statistically probably
improbable
i think that
let me ask
when do you think the the the so it's
happening now right i think we're i
think we're in the the last days yeah i
think we're in the end times how much
time do we have i says no man knows the
day or the hour that's part of the
reason because it says that you know
what's crazy is it says that when these
things are coming to an end when god
comes to rapture his people
but there's no rapture is not mentioned
he says that it will be caught up yes it
is it says they'll be caught up in it
the word rapture is not
that's an english word an american word
yes so i'm saying that it says being
caught taken off so what it actually
talks about is very interesting because
this happened with with enoch and other
people in the bible but what is really
really interesting about this i'm saying
is that it categorizes this idea it's
it's very interesting it even like kind
of like predicts the theory of evolution
and whatnot that it says that that
during this time people are going to be
mocking god because it says they're
going to be buying and selling in trade
being given in marriage and living life
as it is saying that life has always
been and it always will be that there
was never this that it's been going for
a long time and it's going to continue
to evolve and continue to move on the
way that it's been and people are just
going to be it's going to be caught up
in their own lives in their own sin in
their own focus and then what god's
going to come back to judge the world
and it's going to catch them off guard
like a thief in the night that he's
going to come back and it's going to
throw everybody off and that's kind of
crazy because even with covet it's like
you're just living and buying and
selling and trading and living life then
all of a sudden the world changes and we
see that where things just change in an
instant i know you guys don't believe it
but that's
what i saw this movie and i guess you
know spoiler alert for anybody who wants
to see the movie antidote i saw it on
amazon is actually pretty good so uh
well i'm just giving everybody a spoiler
warning give him a few more seconds for
us to catch up and then realize if you
want to see the movie
it is uh about a woman who wakes up in a
hospital
where they torture people but then give
them a healing serum to regenerate them
and then continue doing experiments on
them
and so they do things where they cut
their eyes out or cut out their tongue
or impale them and then heal them and
then keep doing it cut their legs off
and uh spoiler warning for anybody who
wants to see it because it actually is a
pretty good movie
all right here we go
uh it actually turns out and i caught
this immediately so maybe it's not a
spoiler she the main character wakes up
in her bed and she's like something's
wrong like my stomach hurts and her
husband rushes her to the hospital and
then she has to go for a uh you know
she's appendicitis what's it called
appendectomy and then she really hurts
just by the way so they they give her
the anesthetic she goes out they go in
surgery and then she wakes up in this
hospital where she's in a different room
it's a different doctor and her scar is
healed she can still see the scar but
it's mostly healed she's like how long
have i been here and i immediately said
she's dead she's in hell
and so i guess the idea of the movie is
that she's in the layer of level of hell
where they torture you and then heal you
and then torture you over and over again
for eternity and the story was that she
used to be a drug addict and she was
dating this guy who was abusing her and
then one day when he was abusing her she
grabbed something and swung it at him
and slashed his throat accidentally
killing him and then strung him up with
piano wire to get away with the crime
and she was condemned to an eternity of
being tortured literally in eternity and
i'm like
man if that's that's really messed up
like this idea of of you know
you you're defending yourself and you
accidentally kill somebody and then you
panic and now you have to literally go
to this hell where you get your legs
chopped off you get stabbed in the chest
they cut your face off and so i think
about stuff like that and i'm like if
god after everything we've seen with all
the evil and and the power of the evil
to manipulate and lie cheat and steal
and trick people and all that for god to
come down and be like i'm judging
everybody and these good people of good
conscience and ethics who didn't worship
me and didn't have faith in me you're
all going to go to hell too even though
it was the evil that tricked you but
didn't you say about cops that they're
they're not good if they don't quit
based on those things so meaning like
how are what defines being a good person
then if god
defines what that none of us are good no
not one because we're born into sin so
he's saying that the only way to be to
actually become and find redemption is
through the faith in the work of christ
so what what happens to the
non-believers when the rapture happens
well not everyone believes not even
everyone believes in that the rapture is
but let's just say in your in your view
like god will come to judge everybody i
think that a lot of people will wake up
because i believe that a lot of people
are familiar with this and they will
realize because the bible talks about
that a lot of people refuse to get the
mark and the the punishment is beheading
they actually get beheaded in the
guillotine style thing they get their
heads chopped off if you don't submit to
the one world government and that's
because you're seen as an enemy because
even though you're just not buying
selling and trading you're a threat like
a terror threat all right so what's
going to happen so i'm saying that it
seems that it seems that a lot of people
get killed that a lot of people who
appear i would assume of good conscience
realize oh crap that was right and that
they become they give their lives to god
that's what it seems like so what i'm
saying is there's obviously going to be
a lot of people
who are problems who are good people in
that they uh uh you know so i'll use my
look i believe in god but i don't
believe in christian theology so you
know
would i be condemned to hell because i'm
like yeah it's about because kezia she
and i have conversations about this all
the time elijah's wife um because she's
you know very christian as well and the
way that she's described it to me is
that it's not necessarily about your
it's actually it is actually about
whether or not you fully actually
believe in god it's not about your good
works it's not about um any of that sort
of stuff it's about whether or not you
effectively like let him into your life
but the good works would follow so it's
kind of like sure sure i could say i'm a
car but it doesn't make me when i can
make the noise and the sounds but it
doesn't make me a car like yeah you
could say like i do believe in god but
faith like you mentioned if you believed
in god and you would get to know his
heart that that should that would he
would transform you and that you would
become more like god you would see this
with a lot of people who genuinely have
real conversion and they become
christians that there's a radical change
in there so i don't i don't i don't who
are hypocrites though i'm a christian
but who don't actually
they're not actually christian if you
know what i mean like and i'm not here
to judge anybody because what the hell
do i know because i'm i'm not religious
why why would i
you know pledge anything to to an entity
that would condemn sydney to hell
well he's not condemning sitting in hell
sydney's choosing to go
right but also i mean by the way so like
doing to eternally torture and cause
suffering for someone
but it's not based out of ignorance
because actually he's smarter than me so
so this is the point this is actually
hyper-intelligent i don't think sydney
i don't think sydney's stupid and i
actually used to be agnostic i've said
that i used to be agnostic um
you know i didn't really know what i
believed um but i but i did know that
it's what's interesting about this is is
that this is also beyond just the
physical that there is an actual such
thing as the spirit of a person of a man
and that these things that's why we
could be immoral or moral versus dogs
are instinctual right these are animals
they don't they don't have the soul this
is what this is distinctionalized about
sentience about the person of who i am
as a human being this makes me sacred
and special god designed me in his image
and so someone like sydney sydney is not
dumb and i thoroughly and fully believe
that when i met sidney she was an
atheist now she's agnostic who knows
where she's headed now um but i do
believe that for instance god put us in
our lines together that's why we have a
new show coming out together let's let's
fight each other we're going to go to
super chats
we will fight each other on the news
let's have an extended conversation for
the members podcast on all this stuff
because i find it really fascinating so
timcast.com check it out uh what when we
were the atheists and the christian go
head-to-head we love each other we do
actually i love elections
when we wrap up the show we then
immediately start pre-recording we we
record the member segment then upload it
around 11 or so p.m on the website and
so go there become a member and smash
the like button
share the show really sharing is the
most powerful thing you can do because
then more people watch it and word of
mouth makes everything work better but
let's read some of these super chats we
got from everybody and uh make sure you
smash that like button
all right let's see
whacked out says serious question this
is an interesting question this was this
is from earlier
from eight o'clock ian do you believe in
reality or observation
uh i you would need to define real what
that means um so observation the
observer tends to define its experience
yeah look at these little rocks i want
one here the obsidian rock yeah here oh
yeah this is the big one where we're
both spinning them yeah you both were
playing with it
you wipe it off though
i try a little more did you put it in
your mouth no not yet
yeah can you tell someone what this ian
is you love it yeah it's oh
rice whiskey you guys did he he this is
a very nice box of this and i don't even
like whiskey why am i i tried a very
little bit and i'm actually very excited
to try a little more and this is like
top dollar stuff that's obsidian this is
a good gift he's a very good he's
drinking a lot of in assassin's creed
vol
tastefully
i wouldn't
all right let's see anon nobody says
sydney and tim should do a collab both
have awesome singing voices do you sing
i do yeah oh yeah well we just laid down
a scratch track for a new song we're
working on we should actually get you to
record some vocals now while we have you
and then use them for the song
like right now like literally after the
show walk down and just press the
microphone and then just like record for
30 seconds beautiful yeah done i guess
theoretically we could always just have
you do it whenever yeah i mean i i have
equipment that i can use to record no i
used to do heaps of heaps of music stuff
and then i'm really good i mean i like
to think i don't suck i think that's the
best way to put it but i do play piano
too people find that quite shocking i i
play piano and i sing
yeah yeah piano is beautiful honestly
best instrument i know that you know you
guys
you know my problem with piano guitar
people but with guitar with piano you
can't get the notes between the two keys
do you mean the sharps and flex no
between the sharp and the white key
between those there's no note on a piano
with a guitar you can bend the string a
little bit more and you get more variety
oh interesting you can hit frequencies
piano that's why i like pianos though
it's because everything is like it is
what it is you get what you get
i like both yeah like guitar playing is
like skateboarding and piano is like
rollerblading piano is honestly i but
but i that's how my brain is though i
like this rigid realization
because you're emotional and like i will
find myself playing guitar during the
day and then after 10 i play piano and
get really heady and and the songs are
deeper where like you're more like you
can with the piano too because
especially when you get like minor like
like uh chords or different scales you
end up getting this real deep and somber
mood and so yeah like if you want to
rock out and have a good time you know
get your heart out quickly find guitar
but piano is like it's like a emotional
like soul connection it's it's like kind
of amazing you know who's you know who's
a great contemporary artist that writes
piano music is yuruma um i believe he's
japanese or no maybe he's not like haid
too is really good and um there's isaac
shepard he's wonderful as well i don't
know just i just love piano sorry all
right we got sort of he says we should
send biden down under to box a thousand
kangaroos yes yes i'd pay to watch i
know well they'd probably beat him to
death
well i i just i just don't want to see
kangaroos getting hurt you know like i
don't think kangaroos can consent to a
boxing match yeah didn't they do that
once
kangaroo oh i think so oh no maybe they
are there's like six million what for
every one million australians like six
years yeah yeah yeah yeah have you ever
eaten a kangaroo yes i have as well i
think kangaroo jerky did you like it
yeah it tasted like jerky no no no you
gotta have the no no what happens when
you put your finger in a kangaroo's
mouth
well let's ask you don't do that don't
do that by the way oh hey by the way
don't stick your fingers in cow's mouth
an ex-girlfriend told me it felt good
that she did it i never did it what else
felt good could be dangerous i didn't
ask
all right carry the crazy says
long time member for some caller love
you all please look into the national
archives closed down dude covet and the
effects it has on va disability claims
they cannot receive our official records
because no one is sending them whoa
wow
uh stephen zilligen says i will buy
sydney a ranch tomorrow is illegal
in wyoming aurora or montana yes email
me wyoming good crypto or idaho perhaps
i don't know start your wyoming
corporation yeah if you want to use
crypto i hear they have fantastic crypto
laws for what happens when uh when the
zombie apocalypse happens and we have no
internet
harvey slayer says ian isn't crazy one
way to teach calves to drink water from
a bucket is to have it suck on your
finger i've done it to help wean calves
off formula a little udder
okay that's so cute
that is a nice image of like a little
cow going
that makes sense
r bracewell says elijah and sydney love
your show and you two have some major
support in my area love the fact that
you two take shots at each other and
it's all in fun i see you and stand with
you
i like that people notice though that
you and i give each other mad s h can i
say that though real fast this is really
important tim because you're
on ian you've been in this industry for
a very long time is
people have stopped just talking and
learning to be friends especially
publicly with people that you just don't
agree with most things on like when you
really get down to it yes sydney and i
agree on a lot of tenants of of life but
down to the nitty-gritty we disagree on
about 70 percent of things and yet we
are very close and we are very good
friends and we even able to start a new
show together because
the world has like stopped understanding
the beauty of like hanging out with your
friends where it's interesting and it's
not just like she's not a yes woman i'm
not a yes man we hang out together and
it's like your shows like that do you
have so many different kinds of people
here it's beautiful it's simple there is
the cult and then regular people and
regular people have always been able to
be like well i disagree with you what
you say but i defended the death you're
right to say it or i disagree with you
but let's argue and debate these ideas
but you've had the growing cult faction
in the u.s that are like you're an
apostate or
a non-believer and everything you say
should be banned and those they don't
represent the actual humans you know so
if you look at uh there was a graph we
showed several times showing where
on this chart of like
of economic uh conservatism and
liberalism to social conservatism and
liberalism you look at where trump's
voters are and they were left and right
on economics
and mostly anti-woke
you look at the democrats and it was
hyper-concentrated in communist woke
so you have the the overarching like
american population of economic left and
economic right and their agreements and
disagreements as they've always
traditionally been and then you have
this new emerging faction of cult like
dogma so when people are like why can't
we get along anymore it's like well some
people joined a cult and you can't
communicate with them because they're in
a cult
and that's true for some trump
supporters but for the most part the
people who are in whatever this space is
be it atheist agnostic people who
believe in god or people who are
christians and who are either
conservative or libertarian or somewhat
liberal we all have conversations
getting along just fine yeah but the
culti people are very difficult to
communicate with you know it's funny
that you say that though um and i don't
mean to make this a sydney moment but to
exactly what you're talking about i was
so scared to admit publicly that i don't
believe in god because a large faction
of conservative the conservative right
are very christian and they think you're
a heretic
if you are an atheist if you're not
catholic
they call
elijah would quietly try to out me on
his show he'd be like sir sydney you as
a non-believer and i'd be like shut up
because i was i was scared i was like i
don't want to get attacked i mean it
takes bravery to come out and say
something so brazenly stupid as two plus
two is five but i'm i'm proud of you for
i'm just kidding
jack post said i'm a part of the great
apostasy as he told me he said
he's like he's like i love you but you
know you just you you support uh the
great apostles isn't that funny though
how how it's like christians who fight
within themselves christians fight with
atheists atheists fight with everyone i
don't fight with anyone just by the way
i'm out here just like i don't care just
be nice to me okay buy me a ranch in
montana
yeah you're not you're just like get out
of my house let's read a little bit more
we got hayden he says we need a
constitutional amendment forcing
employees to stop taking social security
taxes and medicare out of employee
checks forcing people to write a check
to the government every year returns are
are only the government taking too much
money from you we need to wake people up
i mean that would be huge if at the end
of the year everyone then paid their tax
or quarterly is actually how it really
works so
uh most people don't understand that
when you make a certain amount of money
you pay quarterly you don't just hold
all your money because then you get you
get fined you get interest so imagine if
every three months people were like it's
tax day how much do i owe
seriously yeah then they'd vote against
that in two seconds yes they would
they'd see how much is coming because
people don't see what's coming out of
their paychecks so they have no idea
what they're paying in tax and when you
see how high that is i cry we we weep
we have a good one here some guy from
texas says here's a list of all the
things that will not kill you in
australia one some of the sheep oh
exhaust some of them
just some of them the rest of them are
poisonous they spit uh they spit gas at
you poisonous sheep yes
rajesh says australians are decent but
inactive and unpolitical being an indian
expat in australia born the uh jn the
communist hellhole of kerala which by
the way is one of the main source of
woke expat professors in u.s
universities australia is not bad
because i can now afford this super chat
hey appreciate the super chat thank you
all right let's see we got here
eric a says in regards to the project
veritas video earlier the high school
news youtube channel did a profile on
the teacher from when he first got there
three years ago really creeped me out
given what we know now titled tiger talk
profiles mr guy you guys see this thing
from veritas oh yeah where he was
talking about how he's turning his
students into revolutionaries it was it
was creepy and but it's it's he's got
that
thing no no but he said do you sell that
but they said they said in the interview
that uh multiple teachers at the school
actually share the same sentiments and
that they sort of discuss their creepy
little revolutionary viewpoints the
mouth the mao picture is what did it for
me on the wall he is now overlooking the
students
is that real
he said too that he had a student who
was uncomfortable with the fact that he
had the antifa flag in his classroom and
he said i'm doing this because i assume
it'll be on the wall and he said you
know basically uh if you have a problem
with this and you're writing like a note
at the end of semester you know
basically complaining about it then
there's actually something wrong with
you student because your ideas are then
antithetical to the
you know values of antifa who the hell
says that to like a freaking 16 year old
what is that
these people who hasn't atomic
what is that they make flags all right
atomic ozzie says australia also has an
anti-corruption department that is used
to protect the politicians from
investigations yes
yes they also have this thing too um god
what's it called um uh they call them
fixated persons this is not related to
the government but where they can
basically institutionalize you um if you
are like posting too much or too
aggressively or writing too many letters
to politicians saying hey i'm angry that
you're doing you know this this and this
yeah they have they call them fixated
persons there's a fixated person's unit
and they can institutionalize you that's
what i'm saying go and look up
psychoaustralian legislation i encourage
every person to do it because there is
so much of it that infringes the rights
of australians in ways that you cannot
they don't really have rights by the way
well we never will this is the thing is
like i think it might have been you
lydia yeah you sent me yeah about how
australian doesn't australia doesn't
have a bill of rights and we don't
yeah
common law it's very bizarre because
even our freedom of speech and i've
ranted about this before is only implied
in our constitution it's not explicit so
there's only five explicit rights in the
context australia thought cpac was an
extreme right-wing meeting so that
there's there's that yeah
wow mr obvious says this was the best
episode of tim cast by far hilarious and
based i think people should follow their
dreams the worst thing that can happen
is they fail the best thing that can
happen is they succeed through hard work
i think jordan peterson said in order to
succeed you have to be willing to be a
fool yeah yeah today he he shouted that
out
on instagram or something like that i
would agree with that yeah
he seems like he's doing okay really
happy he seems
he's been reflecting on on how gracious
people have been to he and his family
over the last how could you hate the man
what a what a lovely dude he honestly
does seem like one of those people that
would just is just like good-hearted you
don't meet too many of them joko boyan's
where we live in texas he's like that
too yeah
he's just a great a good like when you
meet him
kezia described this to me she was like
you'll meet him and he's just got this
energy about him and i don't really buy
into that sort of stuff but i met him
and i was like wow i get it he's a good
dude i think lily tang williams is a
little bit like that very very special
kind of person
paul c says sargon on his lotus eaters
podcast did a fantastic segment with an
aussie political scientist explaining
what's happening here titled australia
has fallen highly recommended check it
out we're big fans of sargon and lowe's
lotus theater's podcast you guys should
definitely check that segment out
because i know i will that sounds really
interesting i'd like to hear what they
have to say
all right let's see
joseph flynn says i wonder if there's
any correlation between the dangerous
wildlife and australians tendency to
trust their government the group
survives when they stand together so if
someone disagrees they're viewed as
public enemy
safety in numbers yeah i mean don't
touch the cone fish elijah
don't step on the rock fish elijah yeah
it's always there's always like that's
no that's the rock fish that's the stone
fish wait to see the pebble fish
it's a sting it hurts but you get over
quickly there's a song by these
comedians and it's like they sing about
all the all the things that can kill you
in australia and it talks about those
red back funnel web blue rings octopus
dorian meredith says i am canadian and
you could not pay me enough to make me
move to the u.s i love my country i am
100 happy here my biggest fear these
days is that the junk happening in the
u.s will bleed into here million dollars
you got to live in minnesota northern
minnesota just on the other side of the
border million dollars what do you say
i got a feeling the answer's gonna be
yes yeah cause you're like right there
you know it's like you're just on the
other side there's a video of like this
like teenager and they're in some part
of canada on the border where there's no
border barrier at all just like just
like a a street barrier you know like
steel block and it says like u.s
canadian border and they're like jumping
back and forth
because there's areas like that
all you gotta do is walk across and
stand there for for for a couple decades
million dollars
couple decades
but you can go hang out with your
friends whenever you want right there
just straight through the board you got
a million bucks now you can buy a cow
stick your fingers in his mouth
all right let's see we got
someone should draw this a picture of
you sticking your finger in a cow's
mouth please
i'm down thank you for being smarter
than me
all right canadian says canadian a says
i have a ranch in canada with cattle and
horses sydney green card marriage save
me from communism you get to play with
cattle and horses we'll keep ian away
from the cavs
no you won't
no you won't
be hopping over the border that'll be
the next thing
do so you guys think horses really feel
the human like beating together with
them you know they become like one when
they ride together i was just seeing
chocolate from black beauty allen coming
being like and then when i realized we
were beating as one i got even more
invigorate and the horse is like flying
you know when the guys like ryan that is
a really nice sentiment from but from
what i know about people who have had
experience with horses they're
exceedingly skittish and they don't
really bond with humans so riding them
is different than like actually unless
you have spirits stallion of the
cimarron that's true that's a bit
different and then you have an indian
boy riding you yeah it's beautiful what
is that have you not seen spirit destiny
movie arguably the best soundtrack lydia
backed me up on this best soundtrack no
what is it great it's a movie battle
horse who just who's
he's trying to find his heart i don't
know it's called spirit spirit stallion
of the simran thank you
unironically great all right let's see
we got uh terese larfield says i i live
in a mining town in outback western
australia lots of cashed up bogans in wa
i will add the tide is turning against
the tyranny our premier was like a rock
star not so much anymore
interesting
ben macklin says western australia
classified gel blasters as prohibited
weapons bb guns that shoot gel-filled
plastic balls because they resemble real
guns yes
you can't buy um some of the some of the
toy guns you can't buy them because they
always search my luggage so deeply when
the border force whenever i go there
they always take me aside and they just
they touch me it's uncomfortable did you
see uh china made it illegal you gonna
play video games three hours a week now
if you're under 18 in china yeah oh
didn't they also ban like uh banning
fake guns
oh sorry interrupt you video no i
interrupted you actually i'm just rude
today continue please put me in the bin
what what happened
we do what would you pretty much been
outside
you wanna go shove me into it but you're
talking about banning fake bb guns this
is like banning digits no no you have to
understand australia just bans
everything just they ban enjoyment no
fun for you yeah
back into your cage they came for the
humor because that's what that that is
everybody has a sense of like we call it
the clown pill right on slightly
offensive people you know gavin says
like once you stop laughing then they
win you know i think other people just
call it like you know the positivity
face or whatever but the whole point is
is that as long as you stay positive as
long as you are able to laugh at what's
happening they do not win over you and
so that's why they come for humor they
come for enjoyment because as long as
you're still enjoying life despite what
they do you are still in control and you
still have power there was a vietnam i
think he was a captain a pilot and he
got shot down and taken prisoner of war
at hotel hanoi one of the infamous like
vietnam pow camps and it was just
devastating for years they were there
and he would do exercises with his mouth
to keep smiling and to keep the other
prisoners
happy and he did and they got through it
and that was a big part of it was
staying
just doing the muscles so that you
remember what it feels like to smile he
would have to do that every day isn't it
easier to smile than it is to frown no
that's a phallus i lift it up i read
that on a meme but apparently it's not
true
all right fact check the things that you
hear tim's like i want to read these
stop talking about stupid things yeah
says tim as a regular viewer i take
exception to your comment on your
earlier segment where you said who wants
to live in colorado i love my guns my
mountains just not the california
implants yep much love and keep killing
it yeah the mountains are great
colorado is awesome colorado is
beautiful many many many people in
colorado are fit and active and they
take it very seriously also a sexy place
full of success just the worst airport
is denver
the creepiest creepy there's like
underground military base there or
something like that some old secret i
thought that that was a also a fallacy
definitely
at the risk of this turning into like a
um a matchmaking show we got so many
super chats from people who are like now
getting trying to buy me a ranch trying
to buy a ranch and they're holding roses
i have an email let's see uh i was
actually thinking elijah sorry to
interrupt you tim i was thinking we
should just you know
put your name in the hat data sydney
then we can raise a bunch of money for
our new show there you go as long as we
get to build the studio of our show
on that ranch and we don't have to live
in a city ever again yeah you can just i
say
i i'm from l.a like i moved from
hollywood into texas and i thought texas
was like the country for a second and
i'm like man i don't i don't want to be
within a few miles of another human
being i need to get out of here i need
to get out of the city sorry tim we
interrupted you continue i was going to
read this guy who's pitching pitching
woo all right
is aaron up says sydney you're single so
i'm going to shoot my shot like the
fresh and fit podcast
29 year new braunfels texas no cows yet
but i'm attractive with multiple revenue
streams and a high iq how do i get a
date
email email uh email what's your what's
your what's your email
for brandon yeah what is it
mercurystudios.com would be her producer
and he can uh filter that out and maybe
set up data for you i will i will say it
would be the greatest thing if like a
year from now there's like a wedding
right here in your compound oh and
they're right here and you guys are you
know and you can have other little
atheist babies that are going down
you know
hey elijah there'll be a legion of us
and then we'll take over i am the dark
lord no people don't realize how tall i
am so it's funny because like people who
she's like six six ten yeah i'm like six
foot 100 but people it's people come up
to me you know they meet me out and they
go
oh and i watch them be like
because they come up and they realize
that i'm just this giant creature and
they're like you know what just kidding
i don't i don't have horse children no
you wear tall shoes
no well yeah i like wearing high heels
you know the weirdest the craziest thing
about meeting you for the first time was
not just that i assumed you were short
or was but but it was that your arms are
really long i know and go pass down to
your shoe yeah like slenderman you go to
your shins
i'm really gonna get her married on this
show exactly
sydney is a giant with slenderman arms
you know what they're good they're good
for like wrapping around aaron aaron is
gonna is gonna get his date and you're
gonna walk he's gonna be sitting there
at the diner and he's going to have like
a flower and a drink and he's going to
be wearing a nice suit and he's all
chiseled and handsome you're going to
walk in he's going to go
she's like i got this she'll get the
check and her arm was just way out he's
like
i take it from the waitress that she's
walking over save the step i love it
really long fingers like
my fingers are long too that's the thing
like you know they're so difficult
people so a friend of mine once said to
me that i have alien hands and i looked
at them and i thought no and then i
looked at them and i thought oh yeah
okay for anyone they're like like those
people who made the clones from star
wars episode two they have those like
long little yes a little the cr
and my nails are and this is the thing
is that you in alien form i can't unsee
it i can't
where are the drawers
i was like where are the troopers all my
nails are like real as well which freaks
people out and they're like that's
disgusting but look look at the it's
everything i'm just a long person were
you always long biotin um yes yes i was
i mean i remember be so i i was taller
than most of the other kids in primary
school and then when i got into i was
probably about 16 i had a growth spurt
and i came back and because my mom said
to me you want to be about five foot
nine sid that's a good height and i
thought
it's a bit tall that makes life quite
challenging and then i came back from um
doing an exchange trip in france and i
was five foot eleven i can't unsee now
i can't that is me i can't
see it
let's give me an outfit let's get me an
outfit like that remember these are the
ones that made the the clones yeah yeah
well that does look like sydney we just
need to get this it's alien sydney
oh my gosh i i feel so bad someone's
gonna photoshop my head onto one of
those yeah you know that right harder
daddy
all right john curry says timothy listen
to seamus coughlin he is a good man who
will help lead you to the lord you know
we had to uh uh we had to wait to kick
sheamus out yeah because he stole the
show and and changed a shim cap yeah
yeah you to need yeah and and and and
all of a sudden the the the graphic that
says tim castner said shim camps
you know i was i was powerless to stop
it
i'm kidding we love you
we let it happen let's be real
all right let's see we'll we'll do uh
we'll do a couple more because i really
want to do the uh there's a lot of
questions about religion and rapture
stuff but we're going to have that for
the members segment because it's going
to be really really fun
brendan saltovic says tim if you don't
want a relationship with god in this
life why would you want relationship
with him for eternity oh i'd love a
relationship in that capacity what i'm
saying is like the idea of hell and
eternal suffering for being wrong like
not being a bad person just you know
being confused or ignorant there's a lot
of people i know who are confused and
ignorant you know like sydney for
instance and you know i try to be nice
to her
ignorant
confused and ignorant with cindy and tim
that's actually a good idea for a good
name for a show
confused gleefully catastrophic because
we run off into the apocalypse actually
that's a really good idea for like a
sketch where you get two regular people
to talk about a very complex idea
without any fact checking or prep time
or anything and see what they talk about
yeah it would be like when remember
remember that smart bot chat ai
they had where you could talk to it
online yeah and it started learning to
be racist yep immediately yeah and then
and then like
but no like because it just it just
repeats back what people were saying
people were saying nasty stuff but then
they made it talk to each other and it
created its own language
i think those were different ais one was
they were seeding it with like racists
nazi stuff and so the ai became racist
the other one was two ais were talking
to each other and they started speaking
a language at facebook and they shut it
down because they were like what are
they saying
that's awesome yeah so that's what would
happen you'd have someone like you put
these two random people and film them
and then after a long enough period of
time they probably have crazy theories
no one's ever heard of that make no
sense
because they're only getting limited
information from each other you know
that'd be great
jake mcgreel says i have cows baby
calves will indeed suck on your finger a
nipple on a calf bottle and a real teat
is about the same size that's what you
want to say so well you know what's
funny is we all we all made fun of him
but he was right the whole time
i guess the issue was you said it feels
good well and i did say yeah i said an
adult cow everyone super chat said they
were baby cows so i don't know if the
adults are still down no no it was the
saying it feels good part that was yeah
that's indoctrinated that's what sticks
with me you know you remember the way
you feel not what the things you you
heard you know often
don't stick your hands in i heard like a
human baby can bite your finger off what
they have no teeth so who do you blame
if they do that do you blame the baby
it's kind of like do you blame the
police officer like who do you blame
like the jaw strength of a human is is
intense even in a baby and they could
bite down and like i break your you know
rip bite your finger off i'm very
curious about that i do know that babies
will hold on to your arm like a sloth if
you hold them like that because it's
it's to keep them from falling so if
they feel like they're falling and
you're holding them against your arms
they'll grab your arm really we should
uh we should test that test the theory
does anybody have a baby we could borrow
exactly to borrow a small child baby and
a calf
all right amy lamarr says
after the rapture those left will likely
have one more chance but they will live
under major persecution god would not
force someone to be with him if they
don't want to be amen elijah god bless
you know what i was thinking you know a
good idea for like a short story or
something i was thinking about where are
all the people where are the truck
drivers where are all the workers all
the labor shortage
and you know like why is the economy
getting worse why things you know why is
there where are people are they just
sitting in their houses not working
what if they were raptured
already and you're left behind
well that would explain it that's why
i'm still here yeah me too
no but you're you're a nice good
christian girl like but friends with you
do you think that
that's where you messed up you messed up
not literally but it is a good question
i think is like where are all that's
right lydia is your dude
okay so where are all the people where
are they they're at home is that like
that's people are quitting because
because what's happened is is
well i would that's a whole other story
but working has become less about
providing and people have lost purpose
and so you know not only is work become
about what what's fulfilling it makes
you feel good and it used to be what
provided for a family or how you could
actually you know bring sustenance into
your life it's become so narcissistic
and it's become so self-involved that
people just don't find meaning in these
jobs and they're not willing to do what
what is qualified and also our college
you know degrees don't help people
anymore so they're lost
i just think that it's i talked to a guy
recently who ran a train company this is
crazy he ran a train i never who do you
meet in logistics and trains and um he
was telling me that you know that
they're hiring truckers right now for
150 000 a year which is good money and
he's saying that people just don't want
to work it because they don't want to
subject themselves to being a trucker
and i don't mean that disrespectful
because it is a good job but they have
this pride complex these young people
like well i'm not going to be a trucker
i'm going to be a youtuber or whatever
and like god knows those youtubers tim
yeah i got to be honest like first
trucker would be a job i would do if i
wasn't doing this
you cannot do any drugs as a trucker
because they test you constantly yeah i
was like i'm pretty sure you can't and
also if you're really careful with
drinking sugar i love it i love i love
truck stops drop choppers
everyone to buckies i can't even speak
english buckies [ __ ] ease yeah you're
gonna be disrespecting your texts and
followers bucky's is a truck stop that
like you said they might have been
raptured and maybe heaven's bucky's
because i've only talked
because no yeah because bucky's is just
the most the largest they would have
called a truck stop but it really is and
it's like the only place you could buy
like fresh brisket sandwiches and also
like possibly don't have like weird
cheese things yeah an electric scooter
it's basically
like target meets walmart meets truck
stop and it's so big it has it has this
like um a rat thing on the front this
the like logo is a rat what is it and
they start at 17 an hour at the cash
register i think and then go up a little
more it's twenty four dollars an hour
and nobody this is what happened i know
somebody who went there and they were
like they were taking it was actually
jacob
was taking a picture of the sign that
said like starting at 17 an hour for
literally having f with it talents or
skills usually don't have nothing for
his job and the guide to cashier was
like don't take a picture of that you
wouldn't want to work here it's horrible
and it's like bro that's what first jobs
are they're all horrible and people
don't want to work that's what i'm
saying all right let's do one more
rips
or what does it say uh a rip stickers
says whatever tim always craps on
college but fails to or willfully
ignores the fact you can major in things
like stem he acts like anybody can just
teach themselves to be something like a
chemical engineer
well no i'm speaking generally about
college because most people aren't going
to become chemical engineers most
regular people are like bouncing i think
i think well like half of all people
will change their majors not knowing
what they want to do you get 18 year
olds who have no idea what life is
because most of them never had a job
then you tell them take out massive
amounts of debt send them to college
they pick a random major that sounds fun
i always wanted to be a photographer i
guess there's no prospects of a job in
that capacity they get out with massive
debt and they're like that sucked
so the way i see it is i'll be quick on
this i used to i was told over and over
again when i was younger you got to go
to college you have to you know why
because the story i heard was about how
you know oh the you know my my friends
who went to college were making six
figures
and you know i didn't i just went into
the workforce i was making half that
that's why you got to go to college you
can get a good job and i'm like yo
your generation didn't have the social
pressures to go to college like you're
putting on us that means without that
an entire generation of boomers saying
you have to go to college the greatest
generation was telling the boomers do
whatever you want to do have a family
the people who are passionate about
being a chemical engineer said if i want
to be a chemical if i want to be a
chemical engineer got to go to college
went to college to pursue a passion
graduated and got the good job they were
passionate about now you've got people
saying blindly just go to college for
who knows what and they can't get jobs
and they're saddled with debt and they
hate their lives so what we need to
bring back is telling people not to go
to college because we need to we need to
treat it like starship troopers service
guarantees citizenship but it's not for
you you shouldn't do this and we should
be actively encouraging people every
step of the way to drop out and quit and
then only those who truly want it will
be like no this is for me and nothing
will stand in my way and the people who
are too weak or didn't want to do in the
first place will be like at least i have
no debt
so i think they have this backwards just
like they had the self
the self-esteem thing backwards because
they looked at kids who were successful
and they said oh they have high
self-esteem this means that kids who
have high self-esteem will be successful
no no no no successful children have
high self-esteem because they are
successful people who went to college
for a driving force ended up being
successful because they had something
that they desperately wanted to do
people who drift into college because
their parents told them to are not going
to succeed or be fulfilled because they
have it backwards we have very important
conversations to have about the rapture
yes so if you want to see they go to
timcast.com become a member because the
bonus members segment will be up around
11 or so p.m and you can subscribe make
sure you smash the like button on your
way out subscribe to this channel share
the show with your friends check out all
the awesome news articles we have at
timcast.com you can follow the show at
tim cast irl where we post clips all
over the place you can follow me
personally if you want to see me
trolling people on twitter with you know
typically garbled nonsense like i said i
tweeted joe biden is the greatest
president of this or any generation
that's right that's right
it's funny and then so follow me at tim
cast uh do you guys want to shout out
your show and your socials and go ahead
sydney no you know i about it well i
want to shout out my channel because i
work very hard sydney watson for anybody
who's interested even though obviously
tim cast is
much more elevated but sydney watson if
you want some cool youtube videos but
also elijah and i have a brand new show
launching actually on the 9th of
september i'm never good at doing these
things yeah you're not i'm not um thanks
for admitting it publicly at least we
have that on the table
um well sydney watson's creative and
called her show sydney watson really
good stuff right there yeah uh yeah and
you can follow her everywhere you follow
follow me as well elijah schaefer my
show is called slightly offensive and it
has been really growing thanks to you
guys are awesome and it's been an
incredible time so check it out and this
new show is called you are here so
essentially what it is is like actually
they originally wanted it at the same
time as this show and we said no
so it's so essentially if you're someone
this is a little bit of a later show for
you or maybe you want more content it's
going to be as of right now tentatively
6 p.m central for one at one hour we
don't get this whole two-hour fun fun
nonsense stuff uh but we're gonna be
going over things from the day on just
culture politics and also just having a
great time together in a really fancy
schmancy state-of-the-art studio because
apparently they thought that was a good
idea to give us a whole crew and
everything because it is a nice studio i
mean if i think people actually like
elijah my dynamic just because we are um
we are male members to each other on a
regular basis and we do have i guess a
lot of discussions well we're actually
friends and the key thing is we came up
with the idea for the show like check
this out because we were like we want to
do a show together i want to talk about
the world and it was like where's the
concept so the concept was like
you know when you're a kid
in like the 90s you get lost in a mall
and you're just looking for that
that map the information so that you can
and you're looking at you're still kind
of confused but there's a little dot
that's like you are here
and you can kind of make sense of the
world by by first thinking of where you
are at in relation to the things around
you and getting this idea of then
finding where you want to go and you
have to have this center point to know
where you are and so it's kind of like
just the center point daily of where we
are and i think that's why it's like
unfortunately it's almost kind of like
dystopian like yeah you are here the
only drawback is you can't look it up i
don't think but if uh i think you if you
go to our instagram accounts if you go
to any of our any of our youtubes you
can find the page uh it's because they
haven't given us our url yet yeah but
you can go and click the uh the buyers
in our instagrams and go and subscribe
means a lot our youtube videos as well
all our youtube videos is in our in our
business getting mad so we're going to
stop shattering i don't do anything i'm
just sitting here it's like i don't know
it'll probably be in the bio of this
video when it's relaunched too
i don't know if you're in like an rpg i
don't know if you guys are rpg gamers
but i just found out they freaking
pushed back out of the new horizon
um until like next year like february of
next year
such a good game but they made a loy in
the new one she's like 45. wow she's not
going to be jump enough of stuff are you
kidding me of course she will no
don't you see that one like slovenian
lady who's been in the olympics for like
30 years they're injecting hydrogel into
her joints i'm not being mean to 45 year
old women trust me like you guys you
know usually what kids by that point
you're like super people but god i mean
eloy in the in the og game is like
climbing up bloody like giant structures
and killing why are they bloody
sorry and they're not blood
bloody what comes out of what all right
all right hey are you are you are you
getting paid by horizon
no i just really like the game it's just
such a bloody good game it's such a good
game sorry i'll stop it's your favorite
game no my favorite game honestly is god
of war the 2018 one i'm replaying it for
like the fourth time yeah it's so i
cause i i love boy
so good
i've played either boy come here
i'm coming it's cute we'll have to go
deeper into that tim hates me so much
we have a website thanks for coming
everyone ian crossland you know you can
follow me and uh to clarify your show is
going to be monday through friday yes
monday through friday live live like
this show an hour before this show
begins and it's like an hour-long show
we should do an earlier hour on the show
and i'm kidding oh my goodness elijah
and i would just be like
yeah well we just decided because we
were like why don't we why don't we take
back the internet and start like instead
of it's okay everyone's got to compete
let's just give people more content to
watch at times they want to watch it and
then also too it's like at the end you
can finish watching and then go talk
about cows getting things stuck in their
mouth
all right all right let's do that ian
crossland.net thank you we're going to
talk about the rapture lydia yeah i'm
also in the corner i'm really looking
forward to the show from you guys i hope
you put it into podcast form so i will
it is available on you are here on
podcast yeah i'm going to listen to it
on my commute for sure you guys should
follow me on twitter.com uh at
sourpatchlids as i attempt to have more
followers and sour patch kids this is my
goal in life please help me we will see
you all over at timcast.com or on 11 or
so pm we'll see what happens thanks for
hanging out we'll see you next time bye
guys
you